Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 211, heute live aus dem Chaos Computer Club in Berlin und zu hören im Internet auf euren neuartigen Rundfunk-Empfangsgeräten. Oder wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr noch vorbeikommen. Es ist in der Marienstraße 11 und man braucht überall aus Berlin ungefähr so, weiß ich nicht, 40 Minuten, glaube ich vom weitesten Weg. Und dann könnt ihr noch live gucken, wie wir heute über Bioinformatik reden. Denn das ist das Thema und dazu begrüße ich eine ganze Menge Gäste, die heute hier sind, fast mehr als sonst überall. Zum Beispiel die Lisa, hallo, guten Abend. Und die Linse.
Hallo.
Und die Carina.
Und am Internet den Bastian, hallo, guten Abend. Und das Publikum des Chaos Computer Clubs Berlin, das vielleicht mal ein bisschen Lärm und Geräusch machen kann. Sehr, sehr schön. Normalerweise ist es, also es ist ja immer der Anspruch des Chaos Radios, ein Thema zu beleuchten, so dass, wenn man noch keine Ahnung hat, aber daran interessiert ist, von Anfang an mitgenommen wird, um dann einen kleinen Einblick zu haben. Meistens ist es so, dass ich mich schon ein bisschen auskenne. Heute werde ich sozusagen hart mitlernen müssen. Denn Bioinformatik ist tatsächlich was, was ich persönlich jetzt so direkt noch keinen Kontakt mit hatte, vor dieser Sendung. Deswegen müsst ihr, liebe Gäste, heute genälig mit mir sein, falls ich einmal so oft frage, hä, was? Aber ich denke, wir schaffen das. Ich möchte deswegen auch ganz, ganz, ganz einfach anfangen, mit der Frage, kann man Bioinformatik eigentlich genau definieren? Weil bei vielen anderen Themen ist es ja so, wenn man da vier Experten am Start hat, dann geben die fünf Definitionen. Jetzt mal bitte nur eine Ja-Nein-Antwortung von jedem einen. Kann man das genau definieren, Lisa?
Krenner?
Nein.
Okay, dann fangen wir hinten an. Bastian, was ist Bioinformatik?
Bioinformatik ist ein ziemlich weites Feld und irgendwie geht es darum, biologische Daten, biologische Fragestellungen irgendwie mit Methoden der Informatik zu untersuchen. Aber das ist schon ziemlich weit.
Okay, aber das hört sich ja schon nach einer sehr genauen Definition, also einem, der man als Anfang an. Carina, wie würdest du das denn informieren?
Ich würde mich da sogar recht anschließen. Allerdings geht es halt sogar in der Bioinformatik oft nicht nur um die Biologie, sondern da ragt noch die Chemie und die Pharmakologie rein. Ja, und die Verfahren sind halt auch wirklich sehr, sehr vielfältig.
Aber da muss ich mal fragen, ist das nicht in der normalen Biologie auch so, dass es dann Schnittstellen zu anderen Bereichen gibt?
Ja, und deswegen ist es eben in der Bioinformatik nicht anders.
Okay, aber schon in die erste Falle vielleicht getappt, ist es okay, wenn man von der normalen Biologie und der Bioinformatik spricht? Also ist das quasi so ein extra Ding?
Ich würde sagen, die Bioinformatik erforscht und arbeitet eben auf der Biologie. Also das ist schon stark verknüpft. Aber es gibt nicht Bioinformatik ohne Biologie.
Ja, okay, das hört sich logisch an. Linse, was ist Bioinformatik?
Ich würde mich der Definition anschließen. Deswegen, ich sag ja, es ist einfach zu definieren. Aber es ist sehr abstrakt, die Definition. Und ich würde sagen, gerade zu der Frage, die du eben gestellt hast, also es verschwimmt immer mehr. Und die Leute kommen auch von beiden Seiten zur Bioinformatik. Also können von der Biologie her kommen oder der Informatikseite.
Das ist jetzt nicht so was, was ich auch gerade frage. Bei vielen anderen Themen ist ja so, also keine Ahnung, die man ganz ehrlich sagt, Medien. Medien kann man halt ohne Digitalkrams überhaupt gar nicht mehr denken. Da sozusagen, also jetzt noch mal von einem extra Digitalteil Informatik herzusprechen, wäre totaler Quatsch. Das ist also bei Biologie auch so, dass sagen, dass in der Wissenschaft, dass immer mehr dazu führt, natürlich, dass da auch Informatik überall eingesetzt wird. Also egal, ob es uns extra so nennt oder nicht.
Ich würde sagen, es geht auf jeden Fall immer mehr in die Richtung, weil es halt auf der Genom-Analyse heutzutage auch so wird.
Okay, weil da so viel passiert.
Genau.
Lisa, deine Definition noch?
Ich würde mich auch basteln anschauen. Ich habe auch gesagt, das ist zu definieren. Die Definition ist sehr weit gefasst. Und damit, ich weiß nicht, wie nützlich, aber man kann es auf jeden Fall recht nützlich.
Nützlich ist ein sehr schönes Stichwort in diesem Fall. Jetzt haben wir diese abstrakte Definition. Es ist halt irgendwie biologische Wissenschaft mit informatischen Methoden. Kannst du mir ein Beispiel nennen aus der Welt, dass man als Normalsterblicher nicht Bioinformatik gleich gehört hat, wo man sagen kann, da hat Bioinformatik eine wesentliche Rolle gespielt.
Ein jüngeres Beispiel ist Untersuchung von Krankheitsausbrüchen. Also EHEC, Grippe.
Was war EHEC nochmal?
EHEC war 2011, war das glaube ich. Die Terrorgurken aus der Hölle. E-Coli Erreger, bis dahin unbekannte E-Coli Erreger, die recht ernst zu recht ernsthaften Krankheitsausbrüchen geführt haben. Und da ging es relativ fix damit, dass der schuldige Erreger sequenziert war und dann auch untersucht wurde, um herauszufinden, wie der zustande gekommen ist, was der für Antibiotikaresistenzen hat. Solche Geschichten.
Also Bioinformatik ist schon mal ein Genom auseinandernehmen?
Fällt da runter, ja.
Linda, hast du auch ein Beispiel?
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist immer, wie das menschliche Genom sequenziert wurde. Also das haben ja die meisten schon mal gehört, dass es das Human Genome Project da gab. Und wenn man so ein Genom sequenziert, dann wird das mit Maschinen gemacht. Und diese Maschinen können aber nur sehr kurze Stücke lesen. Diese sogenannten Reads muss man dann irgendwie noch zusammen puzzeln. Und das ist dann ein algorithmisches Problem, was wir lösen müssen.
Okay, da wirft man einfach in Formatik drauf und dann hat man einfach das ganze Genom irgendwann.
So zu sagen. Verkürzt gesagt, ja.
Ja, zum Detail kommen wir vielleicht noch. Carina?
Ja, die beiden haben jetzt meine Lieblingsbeispiel geklaut. Deswegen komme ich mal aus einem etwas anderen Bereich. Zum Beispiel Patente digitalisieren, auswerten, analysieren. Auch da wird das genutzt von den Pharmafirmen. Also Patente haben zwei Zwecke. Zum einen geht es darum, den Pharmafirmen ihre Daten und ihre Forschungsergebnisse sich zu sichern. Aber auf der anderen Seite auch zu verschleiern. Denn andere sollen ja nicht so genau rausbekommen, was sie exakt benutzen. Und diese ganzen Patentgeschichten mit Medikamenten, die man so kennt, dass es die eben erst mal nur von einem Hersteller gibt oder auch später wirklich andere Stoffe wieder erforscht werden. Damit man das gleiche bekämpft, statt was Ähnliches zu bauen. Das hängt alles damit zusammen. Und die Auswertung dieser Patente, um das wieder aufzuschlüsseln, dass die Pharmafirmen selbst wieder die Patente der anderen Firmen lesen können, auch das fällt in den Bereich der Bioinformatik.
Ist das quasi das, was man normalen Hacking Reverse Engineering nennt? Dass man versucht, Programmcode zu entschlüsseln, in dem man die Signale auswertet, die aus einer Maschine rausfallen?
Ja, so in der Art. Nur, dass es hier wirklich um Textanalyse geht.
Bastian, hast du auch noch ein Beispiel?
Das gesamte Feld der personalisierten Medizin, also zum einen zu sagen, man kann herausfinden, ob man ein erhöhtes Krankheitsrisiko hat. Das beliebte Beispiel ist Brustkrebs. Also wenn Angelina Jolie sich irgendwie operieren lässt, bevor sie überhaupt einen Tumor hat, dann ist das irgendwie, weil Bioinformatiker das Risiko ausrechnen konnten. Oder eben auch andersrum zu sagen, wie gut können eigentlich Medikamente bei mir funktionieren aufgrund meines Genoms und welchen Medikamenten sollte ich verwenden?
Jetzt hört sich das alles an. Bioinformatik ist eigentlich Genomlesen. Ist das wirklich das Einzige, was Bioinformatik macht? Oder ist das einfach das, wo sie die größte Rolle spielt?
Also es ist schon ein großer Fokus, der in den Bereich fällt. Es gibt aber noch einiges rund um, sag ich mal, Data-Mining und Text-Mining, was da auch mit reinspielt. Das sind aber wirklich eher Randgebiete.
Okay, dann müssen wir jetzt...
Was es genauso auch noch gibt, ist viel Bilderkennung tatsächlich. Also die Biologen mögen es gerne im Labor unter Mikroskopsachen anzuschauen. Und wenn man das in großem Maßstab treibt, dann muss man natürlich auch die Bioinformatik bemühen, um automatisch die Bilder auszuwerten.
Was ist da der Erkenntnisgewinn, den die Bioinformatik da bringt? Also wie funktioniert das? Mache ich quasi von einem kleinen, fiesen Bakterium 50 Millionen Bilder und dann wird automatisch ausgewertet, welche Farbe das hat, oder?
Welche Farbe das hat oder auch irgendwie das Vermessen von Zellen tatsächlich, um zu sagen, ist dieses Tumorgewebe abnormal? Und wenn ja, wie sieht es anders aus im Vergleich zu gesunden Zellen? Wäre auch noch ein Beispiel dafür.
Dann würde ich jetzt gerne den kleinen Ausflug machen, bevor wir darüber reden, was Bioinformatik da genau macht, dass ihr mir mal erklärt, was kann man denn machen, wenn man mit so einem Genom, also mit den Informationen, die in einem Genom drin sind. Das scheint ja jetzt ziemlich viel zu sein, wenn sich da quasi ein ganzer Wissenschaftszweig drauf fest setzt. Und ihr jetzt auch sagt, man kann Medikamentenverträglichkeit oder Wirksamkeit da auch, na sag schnell, irgendwie definieren davon. Ich dachte ja immer so, Genom ist, das ist so der Baustein für mich, wie ich mal, also quasi wie ich geboren werde. Der Rest ist dann, der ergibt sich so, aber das scheint ja doch ein bisschen mehr zu sein, was da drin steckt. Was kann das Genom?
Also das Ziel des Human Genome Projects war ja damals, das komplette humane Genom zu entschlüsseln, das heißt wirklich zu lesen. Und was man sich am Anfang erhofft hat, klingt heute etwas utopisch, nämlich, dass man dann genau weiß, wenn man es lesen kann, auch sofort weiß, welcher Teil wofür gut ist, welcher zum Beispiel irgendwelche Krankheiten verursacht, aber auch welcher eben ein Dockpunkt für Medikamente sein kann. Dass das doch nicht ganz so einfach ist, haben sie dann doch recht schnell festgestellt. Und das ist eben genau das, was man versucht, rauszufinden. Weil im Genom ist es so, die aktiven Teile, die wirklich bestimmen, wie was gebaut wird, sind nur ein kleiner Teil. Da ist eine Menge Schrott drin, der einfach dazwischen liegt, den man aber auch erstmal identifizieren muss, welche Teile sind was, wofür sind sie gut, welche kleinen Änderungen in bestimmten Bereichen haben wieder welche Auswirkungen, zum Beispiel einfache Dinge wie Augenfarbe oder so, aber das kann halt auf alles Mögliche dann gehen. Und auch wo gibt es Wechselwirkungen zwischen verschiedenen Bereichen?
Aber das heißt, wenn ich jetzt, ich muss nochmal sagen, die ganz grundlegende Frage stellen, wenn ich jetzt an einem Genom von einem erwachsenen Menschen rum bastele oder versuche das irgendwie zu verändern, dann hat das auch Auswirkungen auf diesen Menschen?
Ja, natürlich, also ich meine, das beste Beispiel ist halt Krebs, das sind kaputte oder eben veränderte, mutierte DNA-Stränge, die das Problem sind.
Und wenn man die abschneidet oder was macht man damit?
Ja, deswegen versucht man sie abzutöten, weil die sich eben wahllos weiter vermehren und deswegen wuchert so ein Tumor sozusagen und man versucht das abzutöten, eben genau diese Sachen mit Chemotherapie, was jeder so kennt.
Okay, ich bin immer noch nicht ganz im Klaren, wie das funktioniert mit dem Genom, weil ich dachte, wie gesagt, das ist nur so eine Art Bauplan.
Ich glaube, ein guter Zwischenschritt ist vielleicht nachzugucken, was ist eigentlich exprimiert von dem Genom. Was ist was? Was ist exprimiert, was ist angeschaltet. Also stell dir das vor, du hast quasi eine Bibliothek, aber welche von den Büchern sind überhaupt gerade wichtig. Also da ist halt so viel Information drin, die ist für alles im Körper gut. Und in deiner bestimmten Zelle sind dann bestimmte Gene sozusagen hochreguliert, wenn du eine kranke Zelle hast oder runterreguliert oder bleiben gleich. Also im Vergleich zu dem normalen Gewebe. Solche Analysen kann man dann halt machen zum Beispiel.
Aha, also die verschiedenen Zellen in meinem Körper, die haben nicht alle das gleiche Genom.
Doch, die haben alle das gleiche Genom.
Aber es ist nicht gleich aktiv, oder?
Genau, ich hab da irgendwann mal eine Computer-Metapher für ausgegraben, welche ja nun hauptsächlich mit Computer-Menschen zu tun hat. Und das Genom ist das Äquivalent zum Quellcode oder Binary. Und die Expressionstaten dazu sind Äquivalent zu einem Trace, also welche Codepfade wirklich durchlaufen werden. Zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Und das unterscheidet sich zwischen verschiedenen Geweben, zwischen verschiedenen Zelltypen, abhängig vom Tages- Jahres- Rhythmus, welcher Trace da wirklich.
Okay, darf ich das Beispiel noch eine Runde einfacher machen und ihr sagt mal, ob es stimmt? Das Genom ist meine gesammelte Musikbibliothek und die einzelne Zelle wird bestimmt welche, die da gerade laufen.
So sind es die Playlists, könnte man sagen.
Dubstep.
Ja, danach Mood, wirklich. Also der Zelltyp ist die Mood sozusagen und danach ist die sortiert.
Oder stell dir vor, du hast verschiedene Räume und in jedem läuft komplett andere Musik.
Also Genom ist letztlich aus diesen vier Bausteinen zusammengesetzt und Bioinformatik versucht, die zu analysieren.
Genau, also ein Genom besteht wiederum aus Genen und die ganzen Teile sind diese vier Basenpaare, von denen man gehört hat. Noch mal ganz kurz zu deiner Erklärung. Was jeder vielleicht schon mal gehört hat, ist eben diese Stammzellenforschung, weil das sind Zellen, die sind noch nie im Ursprungs. Dass sozusagen, wenn noch denen kein, jetzt bei der Musik kein Mood oder keiner Playlist zugesetzt sind, die können noch alles werden. Und deswegen ist diese Forschung so interessant, weil die noch ungetübt sind.
Und was genau macht jetzt Bioinformatik? Was ist da die Herausforderung, wo der mal steht? Weil das hört sich erstmal an nach, okay, es sind halt irgendwie diese Basenpaare. Aber so ein Genom ist halt irgendwie auch sehr lang. Aber das ist letztlich nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis man das durch den Rechner gejagt hat. Und dann kann man da beliebig Software drüber laufen lassen. Was sind jetzt die Herausforderungen, vor denen man da steht?
Also zum einen noch mal zur Länge. Also das humane Genom, komplett aufgeschrieben, sind ungefähr zehn Meter Bücherregal komplett voll. So hat mein Professor das immer gesagt, so mal als Vorstellung. Wenn man jetzt zwei Genome vergleichen möchte, ist da schon eine Menge Text. Vor allem gibt es, wie gesagt, da schon Abweichungen drin, die sozusagen noch keine Auswirkungen haben, auch innerhalb der aktiven Bereiche. Da können Lücken eingeführt sein oder bestimmte Sachen ausgetauscht werden, ohne dass es eine Veränderung ist. Aber man weiß es eben nicht, welche Teile haben denn welche Auswirkungen. Und das ist es, was man versucht zu ermitteln. Da gibt es halt verschiedene Algorithmen, wo man auch wieder versucht, Vergleiche zu machen. Und jetzt kann man natürlich, um irgendwas rauszufinden, wenn man ja hunderte, Tausende, hunderttausende, Millionen Gene von miteinander vergleichen. Und das ist einfach, wie vergleicht man das jetzt? Also einfach nur, sag ich mal, ein Stringvergleich, wo man Buchstabe für Buchstabe durchguckt und sagt, ist unterschiedlich oder nicht. Funktioniert halt schon nicht, weil da eben auch Lücken reinkommen können oder auch verschiedene Ersetzungen, also wenn sich was verändert hat, eine verschiedene Gewichtung haben. Also das ist so der elementare erste Schritt. Da gibt es eine Menge Algorithmen, die sich eben damit beschäftigen, wie vergleicht man einfach diese wahnsinnig langen Strings miteinander, um eine Ähnlichkeit festzustellen und wie definiert man genau Ähnlichkeit?
Puh, das hört sich jetzt wiederum sehr, sehr langweilig an. Also im Prinzip arbeite ich in einer riesigen Excel-Tabelle und versuche die möglichst passenden Formen.
Das klingt jetzt lustig, aber gerade Bioinformatiker, die eher aus der Biologie kommen, machen nicht selten tatsächlich ihre Analysen in...
Okay, also es geht um diese Ausschüssen der Genets. Hab ich hier zu sagen, es gibt eine kleine Vorbereitungsliste zu dieser Sendung und da ist das schöne Wort, Shotgun zu lesen. Was bedeutet das, wenn ich ein Genom sequenziere? Wozu brauche ich da eine Schrotflinte?
Ja, also das ist ein Sequenzierungsverfahren. Also es gibt mehrere Sequenzierungsverfahren. Das erste Sequenzierungsverfahren ist das sogenannte Sanger Sequencing. Das wird auch Kettenabbruchmethode genannt. Also wenn du dir vorstellst, dein DNA-Strang wird aufgebaut, dann werden da ja diese Basen angebaut, A, C, G und so. Und die haben jetzt halt Spezialbausteine gebaut, bei denen die Kette abbricht. Das heißt, dieser Prozess des Aufbauens kann nicht zu Ende geführt werden. Der hört dann einfach an der Stelle auf. Und das kannst du jetzt mit jedem beliebigen Buchstaben machen. Also stell dir mal vor, du machst das nur mit A. Und dann weißt du jede Stelle, an der ein A ist, und es bricht dann ab. Und dann kannst du es der Reihe nach ordnen, der Länge nach ordnen. Also du weißt alle Stellen, die mit A aufhören. Und weißt alle Stellen, die mit U aufhören sozusagen. Und dann kannst du es einfach nur ordnen und kannst quasi ablesen, was da steht. Oh, ich hab gerade U gesagt, weil ich R&A mache.
Das war jetzt ein Insider.
Was ist passiert? Ich hab gerade gesagt U. Das ist U-Raziel. Das ist der Baustein bei dem Äquivalent von DNA, was R&A heißt, was die Abschrift davon ist. Damit hab ich hauptsächlich gearbeitet. Also die aktive DNA, wenn die exprimiert wird, also wenn die in der Zelle ausgedrückt wird, wird die einmal abgeschrieben. Und da ist der Baustein halt einen anderen Namen.
Und das ist sozusagen innerhalb der Bioinformatik schon eine Fachrichtung, eine eigene?
Aber ich bin noch nicht bei der Shotgun, ne?
Ah, die Shotgun, stimmt.
Also das ist das andere Sequenzierverfahren. Da gab es ja dieses Wettrennen zwischen dem Human Genome Project und dann dem Craig Venter. Und der hat glaube ich das Shotgun-Verfahren verwendet, korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege. Und da haben sie einfach das Zerhackt, das Genom, und konnten dann das bestimmen und mussten dann zwar mehr puzzeln sozusagen, aber konnten das schneller bestimmen. Weil diese Sortierung und so ist halt aufwendiger. Also es dauert lange.
Es freut mich gerade so sagen, das klingt doch also eigentlich sehr einfach so ein Genom zu sequenzen. Also es klingt halt nach viel Stoff. Aber ich dachte, dass ist eigentlich, man liest das irgendwie aus, also wie auch immer, und dann schreibt man das halt sozusagen auf, was ist denn jetzt die Schwierigkeit daran, dass es so viele verschiedene Algorithmen gibt?
Das Problem ist tatsächlich hauptsächlich die Länge. Wir haben gerade gehört, es sind irgendwie zehn Regalmeter Bücher oder drei Milliarden Buchstaben und keine Technik, die man zu sequenzieren, also Auslesen dieser Buchstabenfolge benutzen kann, kann diese drei Milliarden Buchstaben auf einmal auslesen. Deshalb bekommt man ganz viele kurze Textfragmente und muss die wieder zusammen puzzeln. Und je mehr Textfragmente man hat, desto mehr muss man puzzeln. Und hier kommt die Informatik ins Spiel. Man kann sich vorstellen, wenn man alle Fragmente miteinander vergleichen will, wie viele Vergleiche man anstellen muss, wenn man auf einmal auf 100 Millionen Puzzleteile arbeiten möchte.
Und vor allem muss man auch noch bedenken, zum Beispiel das Human Genome Project wurde 1990 gestartet. Das heißt, da war auch noch mal die Möglichkeit, was Berechnungen angehen, noch mal eine ganz andere. Also da gehen die Schritte schon, also einfach was wir jetzt können, was wir an Prozessoren, was wir an Rechenleistungen haben, hat da schon enorme Fortschritte gemacht. Aber noch heute ist die Bioinformatik da immer an der Grenze. Also das sind die, die die größten Cluster an Rechnern, an Servern, die meiste Berechenpower da irgendwie brauchen. Und man rechnet immer noch lange an Sachen. Und das ist eben die Herausforderung. Man braucht intelligente, gute Algorithmen. Das war auch am Anfang das größte Ziel, das einfach überhaupt in einer sinnvollen Zeit, die nicht über Jahre oder Jahrzehnte geht, hinzukriegen. Ich meine das Humane Genome Project hat 1990 angefangen und ist 2003 fertig geworden.
Okay, also das, was ich die nächste Frage gestehen wollte, das menschliche Genom ist entschlüsselt.
Ha, nein. Das war ja der große Lacher, als denn die Zeitungsmeldungen rausgaben, menschliches Genom entschlüsselt. Nein, wieder eine Computermetapher. Wir haben gerade mal das Äquivalent eines Speicherdumps gemacht. Damit haben wir aber noch nichts entschlüsselt.
Also Speicherdump muss sie doch noch extra erklären, auch wenn die Hacker wahrscheinlich verstehen.
Achso, ein Speicherupdate. Also man liest einmal den Speicher aus, hat einen Haufen von Nullen und Einsen oder AGCT im Fall vom Genom. Aber was das genau bedeutet, hat die Funktion, meinst du?
Okay, also Karina, du hast aber gerade Ja gesagt.
Ja, ich meinte, also wir haben es gelesen. Das ist es einfach. Wir können es lesen. Wir haben die Buchstaben in der Reihenfrage, aber das ist eigentlich das, was ich vorhin schon meinte. Wir wissen halt noch nicht, was was macht. Und das ist eigentlich, was das Ziel des Humane Genome Projects war, was aber eben nicht erreicht wurde, weil man dachte, wenn man es lesen kann, kann man es auch verstehen. Aber das ist so ein bisschen wie, ich setze dich jetzt vor ein russisches Buch, und dann kannst du die Buchstaben lernen und dann kannst du die Buchstaben lesen, damit du hast immer noch keine Ahnung, was da jetzt für ein Wort steht.
Eine Metapher, die bei mir tatsächlich erstaunlich gut funktioniert. Aber was weiß man denn jetzt schon? Also wo ist denn diese Grenze? Ein bisschen was kennt man ja anscheinend, wenn sich sozusagen Leute schon irgendwie operieren lassen, aufgrund von Daten, die man herauslesen kann. Also was weiß man denn und wo ist die Grenze?
Ja, also es gibt für manche Bereiche, wissen wir zumindest grundlegend, was sie machen. Also wir kennen irgendwie zumindest grob die Anzahl der verschiedenen Gene, also die Teile, die ausgelesen werden, um tatsächlich neue Moleküle zu erzeugen, wissen wir. Und für einen guten Teil davon wissen wir vielleicht sogar auch, was für einen chemischen Effekt diese Moleküle erzeugen können. Und das sind vielleicht 5% des menschlichen Genehums und für die anderen 95% haben wir noch ziemlich gut im Dunkeln.
Aber ist es denn so, wenn du sagst 5%, ist es so, dass die Informationen, die man aus diesen 5% sieht, dass die sicher sind oder ist es noch theoretisch möglich, dass sich Wechselwirkungen mit den restlichen 95% ergeben, wo dann doch noch mal was ganz anderes rauskommt?
Natürlich gibt es diese Wechselwirkungen auch noch. Das ist eins der Probleme, dass man eben, wir haben gerade schon gehört, dass eben je nachdem in welchem Raum man ist und welche Musik man da gerade hört, das ist eben genau das Ding, je nachdem welche verschiedenen Songs gerade parallel laufen, kann sich irgendwie was ganz Neues daraus ergeben. Und wie diese verschiedenen Teile miteinander interaggregieren, ist zu einem guten Teil auch noch nicht wirklich bekannt.
Und ich frage euch jetzt noch mal eine Reihe nach und fange wieder an bei dir, Baselian. Was genau machst du denn in der Bioinformatik? Also quasi wie ist denn, was ist deine Aufgabe oder dein Hobby oder dein Lieblingsthema?
Also ich bin eigentlich von Natur aus Biologe und bin aus der Biologie nach meinem Studium jetzt für den Doktor, den ich gerade mache, in die Bioinformatik abgewandert, weil ich nicht mehr so richtig viel Lust hatte, im Labor zu stehen mit der Pipette in der Hand und fand es spannender, größere Datenmengen auszuwerten. Und ich in meinem alltäglichen Job, was ich tatsächlich mache, ist eben Genome zusammenzubauen. Keine menschlichen, sondern von anderen Tieren, Pflanzen, Pilzen, alles lustige Organismen, für die man noch nicht mal ein Genom kennt, sondern wo man tatsächlich bei Null anfangen muss.
Warte mal, Genom zusammenbauen? Ist das so wie in diversen Science-Fiction oder NISO-Science-Fiction-Filmen? Ich mache das Augen-Genom einer Ratte in das Blüten-Genom einer Sonnenblume und dann erscheint die Augen Sonnenblume oder was genau machst du da?
Nee, tatsächlich eher diese, weil man eben das Genom nicht als Ganzes auf einmal lesen kann, sondern nur in kurzen kleinen Stücken, hat man ganz viele kurze kleine Stücke von einem Genom von einem Organismus, also von einem Tier und das möchte man komplett lesen, also muss man ganz viele kleine Worte zusammenstückelen, um dann auf die drei Millionen oder drei Milliarden bestarben, an einem Stück zu kommen.
Das ist auch schwieriger als man denkt, weil es könnte ja solche Sachen geben wie Wiederholungen.
Genau, ich sitze tatsächlich den ganzen Tag vor meinem Rechner und versuche Puzzle zu lösen. Und genau wie wir gerade gehört haben, das ist auf der Rechnerseite immer noch tatsächlich etwas, wo man dann auch mal gerne zwei bis drei Wochen wartet, um herauszufinden, ob der Algorithmus jetzt irgendwie es geschafft hat, halbwegs vernünftig das Genom zusammenzustecken oder nicht.
Und warum ist das spannender als Dinge in Pipetten, in kleine Petrischalen zu tun oder wo auch immer du rein pipettiert hast?
Weil, dass kleine Dinge zusammen pipettieren, zwar vielleicht handwerklich, zumindest am Anfang noch ein bisschen spannend ist, aber danach intellektuell eigentlich ziemlich monoton, wenn man einmal verstanden hat, was man pipettiert.
Aber das stelle ich mir jetzt bei dem, was du machst, auch genauso vor, weil da kannst du ein Ergebnis ablesen. Hier fällt aus dem Computer ein Ergebnis raus. Also was ist genau der Unterschied zwischen Biologie und Bioinformatik für dich?
Für mich ist der Unterschied, dass man in diesem Fall, wenn man das Puzzle einmal zusammengesteckt hat, kann man auf einer riesigen Datenmenge tatsächlich spannende Analysen machen, was erstmal nicht... Also das Zusammenstücke macht der Computer für einen und in der Zeit kann man schon wieder Datenmengen auswerten, während man in einem Labor steht und pipettieren muss, erstmal damit beschäftigt ist, zu pipettieren.
Das war also der Punkt, warum Bastian gerne Bioinformatik macht. Wir werden da gleich noch ein bisschen weiter drüber sprechen. Vorher gibt es noch eine kleine Musik von Boogie Bellgeek. Danach geht es hier weiter beim Chaosradio 211 mit Bioinformatik. Sehen uns dann bald wieder. Und wir sehen uns dann bald wieder. Chaosradio 211 hört ihr gerade, wenn ihr euer neuartiges Rundfunk Empfangsgerät auf die Adresse streaming.media.ccc.de eingestellt habt. Und es geht heute hier in Bioinformatik. Ich begrüße herzlich willkommen zurück das Publikum und Chaos Computer Club Berlin.
Hallo!
Ihr hört, da ist noch Platz im Gemäu. Ihr könnt gerne noch vorbeikommen in der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin Mitte und dem Ganzen auch live beiwohnen. Ansonsten sind wir hier in der Sendung zu Gast heute Bastian, Carina, Linse und Lisa. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Und es geht wie gesagt um Bioinformatik. Wir haben am Anfang festgestellt, dass man entgegen Vermutungen einiger Gäste hier tatsächlich relativ genau definieren kann, indem man sagt, das ist, wie war es nochmal Carina?
Ja, das ist biologie erforschen mit und zur Hilfenahme Techniken der Informatik.
Genau und es geht hauptsächlich um die Sequenzierung von Genomen. Das haben wir auch schon gelernt. Und Sebastian hat gerade schon erzählt, dass er genau sowas auch macht, nicht von einem Menschen, sondern von anderen Lebewesen. Und dass er deswegen zur Bioinformatik gegangen ist, weil pipettierend viel langweiliger ist als Genominformation an den Rechner zu werfen und zu gucken, ob da was Spannendes rausfällt. Ich würde jetzt gerne auch von den anderen hier Anwesenden wissen, wie sie zur Bioinformatik kommen und was da ihre eigentliche Aufgabe ist oder war. Fangen wir bei Lisa an.
Ich bin da so ein bisschen zugekommen, weil ich eigentlich Vanillinformatik studiert habe.
Nennt man das sozusagen so, wenn man ein, wie heißt das, Bindestrich-Informatik-Fach? Sagt man Vanillinformatik?
Nee, wenn man genau nichts da, also einfach der ganz plain Vanilla ohne Bindestrich.
Ja genau, aber wenn man sozusagen in so einer Fachrichtung arbeitet, dann benutzt man diesen Namen für die normale Informatik. Sehr schön. Vanillinformatik, muss ich mir merken. Hab ich auch studiert. Okay, wieso bist du dann von der Vanille umgeschwenkt?
Genau, ich fing dann irgendwann an, mich für Biologie zu interessieren. Und zwar eigentlich vor dem Hintergrund dieser Do-It-Yourself-Biology-Bewegung, wo ich mit einigen Leuten aus dieser Bewegung in Kontakt gekommen bin. Und irgendwie schien in Biologie furchtbar spannend und im Vergleich zu Computern viel komplexer und abgefackter. Also Computer hatte ich dann so mehr oder weniger verstanden im Großen und Ganzen. Biologie, das ist doch eigentlich so ein bisschen Alien-Technologie. Also es ist hochkomplexe Informationsverarbeitung, wurde aber von keinem Menschen ersonnen. Und genauso sieht es auch aus.
Du meinst, niemand hat eine ordentliche Dokumentation geschrieben?
Ich hab dann halt angefangen, mich mit Biologie auseinanderzusetzen. Und da ich halt aus der Informatik komme, war Bioinformatik ein naheliegender Weg, sich das zu erschließen. Und da von Hand nachzugucken.
Aber ich stell mir mal sofort, diese Hacker-Motivation ist ja vor allen Dingen, dass du Dinge tun kannst und dann Ergebnisse auch siehst. Du programmierst was, du hackst irgendwas und BÄM ist halt was Neues entscheidend. Bei Bioinformatik ist es mir ein bisschen schwierig. Jetzt hast du aber auch gesagt Du-it-yourself-Bioinformatik. Kann man da zu Hause in seinem kleinen eigenen Hacklabor Dinge tun und dann wachsen einem grüne Fingernägel?
Ja, bestimmt. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum man das wollen sollte. Aber gerade bei der Bioinformatik ist ja so, dass die sehr zugänglich ist, weil die Datensätze gibt es ohne Ende, frei verfügbar im Internet. Man braucht keine großartige Laborausrüstung. Man kann sofort loslegen. Es dauert halt ein bisschen und man ist so ein bisschen eingeschränkt in der Größe der Datensätze, die man bearbeiten kann. Aber interessant ist nichts, dass du trotz...
Aber was heißt denn do-it-yourself? Also was genau ist denn das Ergebnis?
Machst du dir selber auch so, was das Ergebnis ist? Gar nichts. Das ist einfach nur Spaß und Freude. Du sagtest hier, dieser Hackeransatz ist ja, dass da irgendwas bei rauskommt, das sehe ich nicht so.
Das war auch nur eine Vermutung.
Ja, das reicht, wenn es interessant ist und man was gelernt hat.
Es ist immer noch eine Ecke zu absackt für mich. Also ich sehe schon, du legst ja Datensätze aus dem Mittelpunkt runter, lässt dann irgendwelche Algorithmen drüber laufen und dann?
Ich habe, was ich zum Beispiel aus Spaß, das ist jetzt kein großer Erkenntnisgewinn für irgendjemand außer mir gewesen, aber interessant war es trotzdem mal zu sehen, das sequenzierte Genom von einer Lymphoblastenzelle, das ist eine weiße Zelle des Immunsystems. Und die haben die besondere Eigenschaft, dass sie von Hause aus das Genom so ein bisschen geschaffelt haben. Also im Vergleich zu anderen Körperzellen haben die ein anderes Genom. Das stimmte also vorhin nicht ganz, dass alle deine Körperzellen das gleiche Genom haben. Ausnahmen sind da Belymphozyten. Und das kann man tatsächlich einfach mal sich genau angucken, wie das dann konkret in der Sequenz aussieht, also in der Genomsequenz. Weil die Daten gibt es im Internet. Und ja, das fand ich ganz spannend.
Also das gibt es halt im Allgemeinen. Dieses selber forschen ist da immer sehr gut möglich. Weil sehr viele der Gendaten, also die Daten von solchen Entschlüsselungen oder sowas, also wo das jetzt ausgelesen wird erstmal, die sind viel frei verfügbar. Das heißt, da ist einiges möglich, was einen interessiert, selbst zu machen, weil man da einfach Zugriff draufkriegt. Also irgendwelche Gensequenzen von zum Beispiel Grippeviren oder auch irgendwelchen kleinen Pflanzen, Viren, Hefe oder so, die liegen halt vor und dann kann man sich damit die runterladen und damit machen, was man möchte. Da drin suchen, gucken, wie sich die unterscheiden voneinander.
Es gibt da noch einen ganzen Haufen Dinge zu entdecken, die jetzt gerade erst in den letzten Jahren so rausgekommen sind. Ich denke da gerade konkret an zirkuläre RNA, nicht so wichtig, was es im Detail ist. Der Punkt ist nur, das ist erst seit 2-3 Jahren bekannt, dass die relativ wichtig sind, wusste vorher keiner. Und die Methoden, mit denen die gefunden wurden, sind eigentlich durchaus für so ein Gamer-PC, wären sie zugänglich gewesen, wenn man die entsprechende Idee gehabt hätte und mal danach geguckt hätte. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass noch weitere solcher kleinen Bits und Details in den Datenmengen, die es da im Internet gibt, zu finden gibt.
Hast du da aktuell ein Thema, an dem du sitzt?
Nö, naja doch so halb. Also da komme ich leider nicht an die Daten ran, das ist ein bisschen ungünstig. Da geht es um horizontalen Gentransfer, also Gentransfer zwischen verschiedenen Spezies.
Und was würdest du da gerne erforschen?
Es gab da einen Aufsatz zu. Die Autoren haben behauptet, dass sie horizontalen Gentransfer zwischen Bakterien und Menschen nachgewiesen haben. Das hätte ich mir zumindest gerne mal im Detail angeguckt, aber der Datensatz, den sie da verwendet haben, ist leider nicht öffentlich zugänglich gewesen.
Was heißt nicht öffentlich zugänglich? Ist das dann sozusagen hinterher, man muss irgendwie teuer so einen Wissenschaftsverlag abonnieren? Oder ist das ganz geheim?
Nein, es ist nicht mal geheim, es ist aber nicht für die Öffentlichkeit zugänglich, weil die Spender, deren Genome da sequenziert wurden, nur unterschrieben haben, dass es ausgewählten Forschungsinstitutionen zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Das heißt, man kann es nicht einfach im Internet runterladen.
Genforschung und Datenschutz können wir vielleicht auch noch mal drüber sprechen. Was das ist, aber ich würde erst mal noch die Runde fertig machen wollen. Linse, wie bist du zur BIO Informatik gekommen? Was hast du da gemacht oder machst du da?
Ich habe Naturwissenschaftliche Informatik studiert in Bielefeld. Das ist ein Studiengang, wo man sozusagen zwei Hauptfächer hat. Also man studiert Informatik und kann dann auch ein Nebenfach wählen. Und ich habe da Biologie gewählt. Man kann aber auch Chemie oder Robotik oder andere Sachen wählen. Da habe ich über einmal so reingeschaut und habe mich dann für Biologie entschieden. Und dann habe ich sehr viel an Dynamic Programming Algorithmen gearbeitet. Das sind Optimierungs-Algorithmen, die man in vielen Bereichen der Bioinformatik verwendet. Vor allem für dieses Gebiet mit dem Vergleichen. Also wenn man Sequenzen vergleichen möchte, dann macht man sehr oft etwas, was Alignment genannt wird. Also man versucht, die untereinander zu schreiben und dabei die Lücken oder Ersetzungen von Buchstaben zu minimieren. Also es ist ein Optimierungsproblem. Das kann man sowohl auf DNA machen, wo man das auf Sequenzen macht, als auch auf RNA, wo man das auf einer Baumstruktur macht, weil die Moleküle auch noch gefaltet sind. Also mega abgefahren.
What?
Das war dann schon eine Doktorarbeit.
Und das hast du gemacht?
Das hab ich gemacht.
Ich versuche auch bei dir die Frage aus, hast du irgendwie so was Konkretes rausgefunden?
Ja, ich hab mit diesem Vergleich zwischen den Strukturen der RNA-Moleküle, kann man halt herausfinden, wie ähnlich die Moleküle anhand der Struktur sind. Also nicht nur die Sequenz, sondern wirklich, wie ist die Form, was natürlich viel näher an der Funktion des Moleküls dran ist. Du kannst also besser bestimmen, wie verwandt die sind, sozusagen mit dieser Methode und zur Verwandtschaft vielleicht noch mal, das kann man vielleicht nicht voraussetzen, wie das mit der Verwandtschaft und den Sequenzen ist. Also wenn wir zum Beispiel jetzt das Genom von einer Maus in einem Menschen nehmen würden, dann würden wir da drin Gene finden, die sozusagen das Gleiche bedeuten.
Ist das diese Nummer irgendwie, dass menschliche Genome stimmt zu 23% mit einer Banane?
Ja, ungefähr so, genau. Weil wir stammen ja von gemeinsamen Vorfahren, wenn man weiter zurückgeht, irgendwo ab. Und deswegen gibt es da halt noch Zusammenhänge, die man auch finden kann. Das heißt, wenn wir Funktionen herausfinden wollen von Genen, dann suchen wir auch ganz oft nach sogenannten Homologien. Also wir suchen nach Ähnlichkeiten im Genom. Und deswegen macht man halt sowas wie diese Alignments. Deswegen ist das interessant, um zu finden, ist da eine Stelle, die ich vielleicht schon kenne und über die ich schon was weiß von der Funktionsweise her. Und kann ich dann was übertragen, zum Beispiel.
Das heißt, du hast optimiert.
Und das habe ich nicht auf Sequenzen gemacht, wie man das normalerweise in der Bioinformatik macht, sondern eben auf diesen Strukturen. Das heißt auf dem Molekül, was schon eine dreidimensionale Form hat.
Ah, ok, dann hast du quasi diese 3D-Form miteinander.
Und das ist ein bisschen näher an der Funktionsweise, weil die dreidimensionale Struktur bestimmt halt, wo kann das andocken und was kann das machen in einer Reaktion.
Hat das dann auch sozusagen, mangelst bessere Worte, praktische Auswirkungen? Ist da dann gleich auch keine Ahnung Medikamentenforschung? Oder kann man gleich sagen, ok, das ist jetzt ganz konkret dafür zuständig, dass man halt eine Krankheit kriegt oder sowas?
Also bei mir ist das halt eher Grundlagenforschung gewesen. Aber man kann das natürlich auf jedes beliebige RNA-Molekül anwenden. Und was ich halt gemacht hab zur Auswertung meiner Arbeit war, dass ich geguckt hab, kann ich die schon klassifizierten RNA-Stammwäume wiederfinden. Also es gibt halt Leute, die haben schon gesagt, man kann das jetzt klassifizieren wie ein Baum des Lebens, nur aus RNA. Und das hat halt schon mal jemand gemacht, weil die das in der Natur so gefunden haben. Und das konnte ich dann wirklich wiederfinden mit meinem Programm. Und das bedeutet, dass das Sinn macht, diese Ähnlichkeit, die ich feststellen konnte mit meinem Programm.
Mir ist gerade eine Frage eingefallen, die ich gerne stellen möchte. Und zwar, ich höre die Beschwerden ab und zu von Leuten, die im wissenschaftlichen Betrieb arbeiten, dass Grundlagenforschung eher sozusagen schwierig ist, weil die keine konkrete Kohle bringt. Und alles, was ihr jetzt hier erzählt, hört sich momentan noch so an, wie es gibt diesen riesigen Datenberg, den wir immer noch nicht fertig durchsucht haben, den wir immer noch nicht richtig verstehen. Und eigentlich werfen wir die ganze Zeit Algorithmen drauf und hoffen, dass dann zu sagen, am Ende was rausfällt, was uns bei diesem Verstehen hilft. Aber es gibt halt kein ganz konkretes Ziel. Wir bauen jetzt ein super Medikament gegen Akne-Pickel, weil das lässt sich supergut verkaufen. Ist es schwierig, diese Grundlagenforschung zu machen?
Oder?
Also ich würde sagen, man kann das tunen. Also es ist schon so, dass es Probleme gibt, wo man das jetzt anwenden könnte. Also zum Beispiel gibt es RNAs, die auch regulieren, was in der Zelle exprimiert wird. Das heißt, das ist natürlich total interessant, um herauszufinden, wie kann ich Krebs bekämpfen oder solche Sachen. Und wenn man dann wirklich auf solche Sachen das anwenden würde, dann würde man natürlich viel bessere Forschungsgelder bekommen. Ist klar. Aber in der Doktorarbeit war das noch ganz okay. Da ist man in der Graduate School, da gibt es schon Geld.
Carina, sahst du aus, als würdest du dazu etwas sagen wollen?
Ja, und zwar muss man vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen weitergehen, weil es gibt ja nicht nur sozusagen die Reihenfolge der Aminosäuren, also AC, G und T, wie die hintereinander sind, sondern Linse hat ja gerade schon darauf reingegangen, dass es da noch Faltungen gibt. Und zwar gibt es da Primär- Sekundär- Tertia- und Quaterstruktur. Das bedeutet, dass nämlich dieses, also wenn wir bei der DNA anfangen, dann wird daraus, da will ich vielleicht gar nicht so im Detail eingehen, erst mal RNA durch dieses Ableseverfahren und so, und dann ist da dieser Weg zum Protein. Und was dabei passiert, ist, dass ganze, also das teilweise Schnips rausgeschmissen werden, die eben nicht benötigt werden, das passiert alles in der Zelle. Und am Schluss faltet sich das Ganze zum aktiven Molekül. Und diese Faltung ist noch mal ein sehr spannendes Ding, weil die Funktion eines Genes, sozusagen, ist nicht nur definiert, oder des Proteins am Schluss ist nicht nur definiert in dieser Zeichenfolge des Gens, sondern auch, wie sich das faltet. Und das hängt davon ab, wie wirklich die Reihenfolge ist und ganz viele Randbedingungen. Und dann wird das so, ja, man kann sich das vorstellen, es sieht oft aus, wie wenn man Papier nimmt, zusammenknüllt und das sieht irgendwie wirr aus. Es gibt irgendwelche Taschen, es gibt irgendwelche Herausbuchtungen oder so. Und zum Beispiel in der Pharmakologie ist es halt so, zum Beispiel Medikamente wirken so, die suchen sich halt genau diese Nischen und können da irgendwie andocken. Wenn aber nur irgendwo was ein bisschen anders gefaltet ist, passt das plötzlich nicht mehr. Und gerade dieses Falten ist noch mal ein Forschungspunkt, wo man versucht, können wir von der Struktur vorhersagen, also von der Sequenz, von den Buchstaben hintereinander, also zu versuchen, vorher zu sagen, wie sich das falten wird und wie das am Schluss genau aussehen wird, ist was, da wird super viel dran geforscht, ist aber fast unmöglich rauszukriegen, weil da einfach so viele Wechselwirkungen sind. Vielleicht kennt ihr den einen oder anderen, das ist noch aus dem Chemieunterricht, da gibt es ja diese Van der Waalskräfte und was so auf Atomebene, Elektronenbindungen, die eingegangen werden und so, das spielt da alles rein. Das sind ja irgendwie 6 oder 7 Bindungsarten, die es gibt. Und die stehen alle in Wechselbeziehung zueinander. Und dazu auch noch, wie das umgeben ist von anderen Proteinen, in welchem Kontext das ist, was da noch drumrum ist. Alles beeinflusst das, dass es wirklich fast gefühlt wahllos ist, wie so ein Stück Papier zerknölen. Du kannst es ganz schwer vorhersagen, aber wenn du weißt, wie das gefaltet ist und wie das aussieht, kannst du dir überlegen, wie dein Medikament, was da wirken soll an dieser Stelle, wenn du weißt, das ist die Stelle, die ich brauche, aussehen muss, damit das da randocken kann. Das ist sogar gar nicht so weit weg. Das ist schon ziemlich nahe an der Anwendungsforschung. Das machen auch die großen Firmen, versuchen, das eher rauszugehen, um zu gucken, wie können wir unser Medikament designen. Früher war es so, dass die meisten Medikamente durch Zufall entdeckt wurden. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist Viagra. Ich weiß nicht, ob alle die Geschichte kennen, aber Viagra war eigentlich eine Idee für ein Kreislaufmittel, bzw. ein Herzmittel. Das wurde Leuten gegeben. Das war schon in der Testphase am Menschen. Dann hat man festgestellt, das hilft, aber wir haben schon Medikamente, die sind besser. Uns so richtig helfen geht, aber lohnt sich nicht. Ist kein sinnvolles Medikament, stellen wir ein. Die Studie wurde abgebrochen. Es hieß, gib mal die restlichen Tabletten her. Dann fingen an, einige rumzudrucksen. Nee, mir helfen die total. Ich will die unbedingt weiternehmen. Oder andere, ich hab die verloren. So viele, dass die Wissenschaftler stutzig wurden. Dann sagten sie, rück doch mal raus. Das ist aber schon so lange her. Da waren wir noch sehr prüde um dieses Thema. Bis dann jemand rumdruckste und sagte, ja, so sollte ich diese Medikament nehmen. Das funktioniert viel besser und kann ich die nicht weiter haben. Dann haben die sich gesagt, okay, Moment. Das müssen wir uns mal angucken. Haben das getestet, festgestellt, wow, da wirkt das. Das sind nämlich die gleichen Rezeptoren. Wo Viagra wirkt, gibt es dann drei Stellen. Schwellkörper im Penis, im Herz und in den Augen. In Informatiker kommt jetzt der schöne Witz. Eine Nebenwirkung dieser Tabletten kann sein, was da passiert ist ja, dass dieser Schwellkörper angeregt wird. Wenn im Auge dieser Schwellkörper angeregt wird, dann sieht man bläulich. Was vielleicht die Farbe dieser Medikamente auch erklärt. Aber gleichzeitig ist es auch noch, dass es den Schwellkörper im Herzen betrifft. Das heißt, das Herz schwillt ein bisschen zu. Deswegen Viagra eigentlich gerade nicht für ältere, etwas ungesunde, vielleicht auch kräftige Menschen. Also genau die, die es am ehesten vielleicht nehmen, verschrieben werden darf. Und es kann zu Herzinfarkt führen und zu Blauen sehen. Bei uns war das direkt der Witz mit dem Blue Screen of Death. Jeder Informatiker aus der Windows Welt kennt das doch. Oder jeder, der in Windows hat das bestimmt schon ein paar Mal gesehen. Das ist so, wie früher Medikamente gefunden wurden. So ist Penicillin gefunden worden, so ist Aspirin gefunden worden. Aber wir können jetzt irgendwann nicht mehr auf diesen Zufall bauen. Also versucht man eben rauszufinden, gezielt, was ist denn da? Was kann ich damit machen?
Also die Nutzverständnisfrage nochmal. Ich finde sozusagen raus, welcher Teil des Genoms mit der Krankheit zu tun hat. Versuche dann rauszufinden, wie dieser Teil des Genoms aussieht in dieser 3D-Form. Und dann versuche ich etwas zu bauen, was in diese 3D-Form reinpasst. Und das ist dann das Medikament. Grob vereinfacht.
Ganz ill. Das ist eigentlich genau das Verfahren. Nur, dass das eben jetzt trivial klingt, aber in Wirklichkeit da so, also dieses, ich versuche hervorher zu sagen, wie das ist, dass halt total schwierig ist.
Vielleicht, Longshot, aber weil du immer von Faltung sprichst, es gab da so ein Projekt Folded At Home, hat das damit zu tun? Da ging es auch irgendwie um Moleküle.
Ja, das ist genau das. Also Folded At Home war Proteinfaltung auf dem eigenen Rechner. Man kennt ja vielleicht noch dieses SETI At Home.
Wo man nach außerirdischen Signalen gesucht hat. SETI war, man hat also Funksignale, die von einer großen Schüssel aufgefangen wurden, und irgendwie analysiert auf, ob da sinnvolle Signale drinstecken. Und Folded At Home macht dann jetzt genau was?
Macht Proteinfaltung, aber auch in einem verteilten Rechensystem, an dem du dann teilnimmst. Und es ist sogar auch ein Wettbewerb, meine ich. Also wir haben das auf unserem Uni-Wohnheim-Server laufen lassen und haben da teilgenommen und waren da tatsächlich in irgendeiner Liste dann.
Braucht man, also ist das, geht es denn um die verteilte Rechenzeit? Oder hat das auch schon damit zu tun, dass man, was Lisa meinte, dass man halt sagen, do it yourself, da Dinge tun kann?
Also bei Folded At Home nicht so wirklich. Da geht es nur um die Rechenzeit. Es gibt aber auch noch andere Projekte, wie zum Beispiel Eterna. Da geht es um RNA-Sekundärstrukturen, wo der Benutzer nicht nur seine Rechenzeit zur Verfügung stellt, sondern wirklich aktiv anfängt, dieses Molekül zu falten, weil die Initiatoren sich, glaube ich, gedacht haben, dass man darüber auf interessante neue Lösungen kommt. Also vorgegeben ist eine bestimmte Sekundärstruktur und die Benutzer müssen Vorschläge ausprobieren, welche Primärstruktur, also Sequenz, zu dieser Sekundärstruktur führen könnte.
Es gibt auch noch ein anderes, da geht es um Docking, also eben wie Moleküle, ob jetzt Medikament oder was ineinander greifen können. Weil der Mensch so ein gutes räumliches Sehen hat, das funktioniert halt viel besser, oder Vorstellungskraft auch, als alles, was der Rechner teilweise so richtig gut kann, da gibt es nämlich auch so ein Spiel als Puzzle, wo man Level für Level durchkommt und sagt, wie würde das am besten ineinandergreifen. Da muss man versuchen, möglichst optimal wenig Leerräume oder irgendwas zu lassen. Und das nutzen die, um wieder Algorithmen zu optimieren und zu trainieren und zu sagen, das ist das beste Ergebnis, was es gibt.
Und da wurden auch tatsächlich schon Sachen mitgefunden, also Strukturen, die man sonst so nicht mit den normalen Vorhersagealgorithmen gefunden hatte. Also diesen Aeternamenchen habe ich schon mal auf einer Konferenz gesehen und da hat er das vorgestellt, dass er so ein Beispiel hatte, was wirklich von der Community dann gefunden wurde.
Okay, also es gibt zu sagen Grundlagenforschung, es gibt auch diese ganz konkrete Forschung. Meine Frage vorhin zählt ja darauf ab, also wie gesagt, weil sie von anderen Wissenschaftsberechen gehört haben, dass da die Grundlagenforschung vernachlässigt wird oder bzw. nicht so gut finanziert wird, zugunsten der, wir finden hier das tolle nächste Viagra zum Beispiel. Ist das in der Bioinformatik auch schon ein Problem, dass gezielt nur noch nach solchen Dingen gesucht wird oder ist die Grundlagenforschung da schon, hat ja noch einen guten Stand?
Also gerade in den letzten Jahren gibt es das Problem, dass es im Pharmabereich eine Entwicklung gibt in die Richtung, dass man sucht ein Sekundärnutzen von Medikamenten. Das ist genau das, was bei Viagra durch Zufall gefunden wurde. Es war eigentlich das Ziel, das eine zu tun. Hier ist die Idee, es gibt ein Medikament, das ist schon auf dem Markt, das hat einen Nutzen, das funktioniert auch, und man sucht jetzt, wofür kann man es noch benutzen. Weil der Grund ist, man spart sich die ganze Forschung, man spart sich die Zulassungsverfahren, die Testsverfahren, was natürlich sehr, sehr aufwendig und kostenintensiv ist. Also geht es um Milliarden. Und kann einfach dieses Medikament für einen neuen Zweck, den man nur nachweisen muss, nochmal zulassen. Und das wird halt viel gemacht, weil damit kann man Geld machen, einfach, aber es wird halt nichts Neues erforscht. Und ein anderes Problem ist, dass auch die Sachen vor allem erforscht werden oder da neue Stoffe erforscht werden, wo viel Geld in den Krankheiten ist. Also Kreislauf, Herz, die Sachen, die Leute jahrelang, jahrzehntelang nehmen, täglich Medikamente. Da wird Neues erforscht, sozusagen neue Medikamente versucht zu machen, weil dahinter ein Markt steht. Deswegen gab es schon vor einigen Jahren die Regelung, dass neue Medikamente nur zugelassen werden dürfen. Wenn die wirklich eine Verbesserung im Gegensatz zu anderen Medikamenten darstellen. Also es darf nicht einfach eine Alternative angeboten werden, wo man sagt, naja, die ist genauso gut wie das, was es schon auf dem Markt gibt. Aber wir bringen halt noch was raus. Weil damit da nicht so viel Forschungsrein gelten, oder eben die Medikamente da nur entwickelt werden, sondern stattdessen wirklich weiter geforscht wird an anderen Krankheiten, die nicht so lukrativ sind. Also zum Beispiel Alzheimer oder so. Da ist es relativ schwer, Forschungsgelder zu kriegen, obwohl das viele beeinflusst, weil es einfach nicht so interessant ist wie ihr Herzkratelauf. Finanziell gesehen.
Vielleicht kann Bastian sich dazu mal ausleihen als der Einzige, der gerade wirklich im Wissenschaftsbetrieb arbeitet?
Na, ich denke ja. Natürlich ist es auch in der Bioinformatik ein Problem, dass wenn man sagen kann, man kann damit Krebs heilen, dann kriegt man das Geld eher hinterher geworfen, als wenn man sagt, ich forschte an den Verbreitungsmuster von Schnecken und brauch dafür Bioinformatik. Das kriegt eher nicht so viele Gelder im Vergleich. Andererseits muss man sagen, dass natürlich die Bioinformatik, wir haben als Arbeitsdefinition hier eine relativ weite Definition irgendwie am Anfang ja festgelegt. Und natürlich viele der Algorithmen und Methoden, die man irgendwie in dem pharmanahen Bereich verwendet, kann man genauso gut dann auch auf seine Schnecken zum Beispiel anwenden. Von daher denke ich, dass gerade in der Bioinformatik man auch davon profitiert, wenn man Methoden nutzen kann, die halt aus einem anderen Bereich kommen. Von daher ist das Problem, glaube ich, ein bisschen kleiner als in der traditionellen Biologie.
Und kann da auch, oder andersrum, ihr habt ja vorhin gesagt, man kann halt schön alleine forschen, weil es gibt ganz viele Daten im Netz. Ist das weiterverbreitet als in anderen Forschungsgebieten?
Ich denke gerade aufgrund von Projekten wie 23andMe ist das schon ein ganz guter Schritt in die richtige Richtung, weil man eben auch einiges machen kann. Daten sind eher verfügbar. Also nochmal kurze Erklärung, 23andMe, wer das noch nicht kennt, da geht es darum, dass man sein eigenes Genom, sozusagen eine Blutprobe, wohin schicken kann. Weiß nicht genau, wie viel es kostet. Ich glaube, 100 Dollar hat es mal, ich weiß nicht.
Es sind 99 Dollar und man schickt eine Speichelprobe zu denen und bekommt dann seinen eigenen G-Datensatz zurück.
Aber Open Snip ist eh viel cooler.
Okay, halt. An dieser Stelle brechen wir kurz, spielen eine kleine Musik und dann erklären wir ganz genau was Open Snip und 23andMe ist und wie uns das vielleicht weiterhelfen kann mit den Daten, die dadurch entstehen. Bis gleich beim Chaosradio 211 hier in Berlin in der Marienstraße 11. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio 211 aus den Räumen des Chaos Computer Clubs in Berlin, wo es heute zusammen mit Bastian, Carina, Linso und Lisa um Bioinformatik geht. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Bastian, bist du noch da? Bastian, nämlich aufgrund hochmoderner Computertechnik zugeschaltet live aus dem Internet hier in das Studio, sag ich schon, in die Räume des Chaos Computer Clubs in Berlin. In Marienstraße 11, falls ihr euch noch auf den Weg machen wollt und vorbeikommen möchtet. Wir sprechen über Bioinformatik, haben in der ersten Stunde schon gelernt, das hat irgendwie fürchterlich viel mit Genomsequenzen und dann Algorithmen zu tun. Und haben schon ein bisschen auch über die Forschung gesprochen und waren jetzt gerade angekommen, dabei, dass es Dinge gibt, wo man als normaler Mensch profitieren kann von der Bioinformatik, nämlich man kann seinen Genom in Form einer Speichelprobe, man kann seine Speichelprobe hinschicken und bekommt dann seinen Genom zurück. So genau. Da gibt es den einen professionellen Anbieter, den man gehört hat, 23andMe, war glaube ich irgendwann mal mit Google verknüpft, ist es mittlerweile glaube ich nicht mehr. Und dann gab es noch Open Snip, es gibt ja immer eine Open Source Variante, so hört es sich zumindest für mich an. Noch mal kurz erklärt, was kann dieses 23andMe und was habe ich davon oder warum macht man das überhaupt? Warum will man das? Will man das überhaupt?
Weil wir haben hier mit Bastian den Open Snip Experten schlechthin.
Genau, das Open Snip ist nämlich auf meinem Mist gewachsen. Aber fangen wir mit 23andMe an. Es gibt 23andMe und andere Firmen, zu denen man wie gesagt seine Speichelprobe hinschickt. Die machen dann die ganze Laborarbeit mit dem langweiligen Puppetieren und am Ende bekommt man sein eigenes Genom oder zumindest einen Teil davon zurück. Den Teil ziehen sie in den Schluss mit an und dann kriegt man, zumindest früher bekam man auch noch eine Auswertung dazu eben, was für Krankheitsrisiken man hat. Ob man ein höhtes Risiko hat für Prostatakrebs, für Brustkrebs, für Alzheimer, Parkinson und noch eine ganze Reihe anderer lustiger Krankheiten und nicht so lustiger Krankheiten. Und das ist momentan eingestellt, diese Gesundheitsauswertung, weil die Food & Drug Administration in den USA 23andMe untersagt hat, diese Tests zu machen, weil sie keine Genehmigung dafür hatten und auch bislang noch nicht wieder haben. Und was sie auch noch machen, ist natürlich eine Auswertung irgendwie. Wir haben gerade schon über Abstammungen geredet im größeren Maßstab, wie ganze Arten miteinander verwandt sind, aber 23andMe schaut sich eben auch an. Haben sie eigentlich in der Datenbank noch andere Leute, die mit einem verwandt sind irgendwie? Also findet man unter Umständen entfernte Verwandte, von denen man vielleicht noch gar nichts wusste, oder wenn die eigene persönliche Historie vielleicht aus, also für US-Amerikaner gerade interessant, woher sind meine Vorfahren eigentlich eingewandert in die USA, dann kann man das mit Wendy Swin zum Beispiel auch untersuchen.
Das heißt, da kann man auch ganz, man schickt einfach zwei oder drei Speichelproben hin und schon hat man einen Vaterschaftstest.
Genau, das ist tatsächlich auch möglicher.
Okay, aber wenn man jetzt gar nichts mehr über sich lernt, sondern nur noch die rohen Daten zurückbekommt, warum wird das dann überhaupt noch gemacht? Ist das dann überhaupt noch interessant?
Das ist immer noch interessant, weil wie gesagt, viele Leute interessieren sich hauptsächlich für den Abstammungsteil. Also vielleicht jetzt nicht für den mehr oder weniger versteckten Vaterschaftstest, sondern tatsächlich umzusehen, vielleicht finde ich ja noch irgendwo der Welt Leute, die mit mir etwas entfernter verwandt sind. Also ich zum Beispiel habe mich über 23andMe testen lassen und mich schreibt eigentlich jeden Monat irgendjemand an und sagt, 23andMe hat vorher gesagt, dass wir irgendwie verwandt sind. Und ich komme aus Kanada oder den USA und naja, wir können ja mal unsere Abstammungsbräume vergleichen. Vielleicht sind wir tatsächlich miteinander verwandt. Das war es bislang nie, aber zumindest...
Wie das heißt, der Algorithmus spuckt irgendwie ein könnte-sein-aus und dann muss man aber noch mal selber drüber rechnen oder wie läuft das?
Genau, der Algorithmus sagt, das ist aufgrund der genetischen Distanz, also wie ähnlich sich diese beiden Genome sind, könnte das ein dritter Cosa von dir sein. Könnte, muss aber nicht.
Und wie genau findet man dann raus, ob es so ist oder nicht?
Indem man tatsächlich einfach mal schaut, wie hießen eigentlich unsere Vorfahren in den letzten drei Generationen und wo kamen die her, wenn man das weiß? Und dann stellt man meistens fest, oh wir sind doch nicht miteinander verwandt.
Ah, okay, also das passiert nicht mehr über das Genom, sondern dann muss die gute alte Detektivarbeit her. Okay, und was ist dann dieses Open Snip?
Open Snip ist eine Plattform, die wir betreiben, wo Leute ihre Ergebnisse von 23andMe veröffentlichen können, in die Public Domain. Also, wenn man seinen eigenen Gendatensatz hat und sagt, bislang hat der nur 23andMe und die dürfen darauf Forschung betreiben, aber ich hätte gerne, dass auch der Rest der Welt Forschung an meinen Daten betreiben kann, dann kann man die bei Open Snip veröffentlichen und schon hat jeder, der einen Internetzugang hat, Zugriff auf diese Daten.
Also, es ist ja so, es gibt von mir relativ wenige Fotos im Internet. Mein Avatar ist ein Bild mit einer Lampe vor meinem Gesicht. Jetzt frage ich mich, ist nicht so sein eigenes Genom, will man das in eine öffentliche Datemang hochladen?
Das kommt auf den Einzelnen an, würde ich sagen. Also tatsächlich für mich war die erste Reaktion als 23andMe mir meine Ergebnisse geschickt hat, noch bevor ich mir mehr oder weniger die Auswertungen, die sie damals noch mitgeliefert haben, angeschaut haben, zu sagen, ich veröffentliche meinen eigenen Datensatz bei GitHub. Warum? Weil wir haben gerade schon viel darüber gehört, dass eben viele Daten verfügbar sind und man als Bioinformatiker oft darauf angewiesen ist, dass Leute ihre Daten frei verfügbar gemacht haben. Und in meiner Arbeit, die ich jetzt während meines Doktors jeden Tag betreibe, das wäre alles überhaupt nicht möglich, wenn Leute ihre Daten nicht veröffentlicht hätten. Sind zwar meistens keine auf irgendwie menschlichen Genomen basierende Daten, sondern auf irgendwelchen anderen Arten. Aber es ist einfach gut, der Community was zurückzugeben. Und das war für mich die Hauptmotivation, zu sagen, hier, andere Leute können mit den Daten bestimmt was Gutes anfangen. Bitte macht das.
Aber wissen die Leute dann auch, dass das quasi dein Genom ist? Oder ist das für die einfach nur das Genom eines Menschen?
Tatsächlich, in meinem Fall ist das mit meinem kompletten Namen verbunden, sämtlichen Social Media Accounts, dass Leute das relativ zweifelsfrei mit mir verbinden können. Allerdings gibt es bei Open Snip keine Verpflichtung dazu, das zu tun. Also Leute können das Ganze zumindest Pseudonym hochladen. Also Leute können sich irgendein lustiges Pseudonym ausdenken, können in der Gefägt die E-Mail-Adresse zur Anwältung verwenden und so weiter. Allerdings muss man natürlich sagen, es sind keine anonymen Daten, denn dieser genetische Datensatz mapfen wir im Zweifelsfall auf genau diese eine Person. Weil selbst wenn man einen Squilling hat, muss man nicht zwingend genau die gleichen Varianten tragen.
Holy, würden die anderen drei das auch machen, ihr Genomal analysieren lassen und dann irgendwie die Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung stellen?
Nö, meine Schwester würde mir wahrscheinlich den Hals umdrehen.
Warum?
Weil sie noch viel größeren Wert auf Privacy legt als ich. Und sie ist halt meine Schwester. Das heißt, die Genvarianten, die ich habe, hat sie zu einem guten Teil halt auch. Das heißt, ich treffe diese Entscheidung nicht nur für mich, sondern auch noch für meine näheren Verwandten.
Ich würde es auch nicht machen. Aber ich würde es vielleicht mir selbst angucken.
Ich denke, anonymisiert würde ich es hochstellen.
Wie viel kann man denn eigentlich über den anderen Menschen lernen? Also wenn ich euch jetzt sage, wenn ich jetzt mit dem Genom ankäme und nicht sagen würde, woher das herkommt, ihr würdet das analysieren, was könnt ihr dann da rauslesen?
Also von meinem eigenen Datensatz kann ich sagen, ich habe den tatsächlich dann auch nicht nur hochgeladen, sondern selbst auch nochmal ausgewertet. Und als kleine Fingerübung, was ich gerne wissen wollte, ist eben tatsächlich mal zu schauen, wie viel kann ich über die Genome meiner beiden Eltern rausfinden darüber. Und ich habe meine Eltern auch tatsächlich gefragt, bevor ich meine Daten veröffentlicht habe, seid ihr eigentlich einverstanden damit? Denn das ist jeweils zur Hälfte auch euer Datensatz. Und wenn ich das veröffentliche, gebe ich viel über euch preis damit. Und die waren beide einverstanden damit. Und bei der Auswertung von meinen eigenen Daten habe ich dann eben rausfinden können, dass meine Daten sind frei verfügbar. Ich kann also problemlos sagen, ich habe ein erhöhtes Risiko für Postdaterkrebs. Und einfach aufgrund der meiner Daten und der frei verfügbaren Auswertung beziehungsweise Assoziationen von Gendaten zu Krankheitsdaten, konnte ich sehen, dass mein Vater das gleiche erhöhte Risiko für Postdaterkrebs trägt und konnte dem dann sagen, hey, pass mal auf, du bist schon irgendwie jetzt 50 plus und solltest eigentlich sowieso vielleicht mal zur Vorsorge gehen, aber mein Genom sagt, du hast das gleiche erhöhte Risiko wie ich, also bitte, bitte geh jetzt tatsächlich mal zum Arzt und sag nicht immer, hm ja, mach ich mal irgendwann.
Was ist das? Ich muss jetzt mal eine ganz uninformatische Frage stellen. Was ist das für ein Gefühl, wenn man über sich selbst und seinen eigenen sterblichen Körper vorhergesagt kriegt, ja, du hast da dieses Ding und das konnte dich möglicherweise mal zur Runde richten?
Ich fand das in gewisser Weise sehr, sehr hilfreich, denn gerade in dem Fall Postertherapeutik gibt es eben Vorsorgeuntersuchungen, wenn man weiß, man ist genetisch vorbelastet dafür, dann nimmt man das Ganze einfach auch mal ein bisschen ernster und geht eben tatsächlich zum Arzt und sagt, ich lasse mich mal durchchecken, weil wenn ich das rechtzeitig erkenne, dass ich tatsächlich irgendwie vielleicht einen Tumor habe, dann kann man was dagegen machen, was man nicht könnte, wenn man eben keine Ahnung hat, was eigentlich das eigentliche Risiko ist und vielleicht deshalb auch überhaupt nicht zum Arzt gegangen ist.
Und wie sicher sind solche Voraussagen? Also ist das dann ganz konkret oder kann es dann auch noch eine falsche Warnung sein?
Na ja, die allermeisten dieser Assoziationen, die man aus dem Genom ablesen kann, sind einfach Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Also in meinem Fall, ich habe ein doppelt so hohes Risiko an Prostata Krebs zu erkranken wie der Durchschnittsbürger und der Durchschnittsbürger hat ein Risiko von 16 Prozent, sagen wir mal. Also ich habe ein 32 Prozent Risiko, irgendwann in meinem Leben Prostata Krebs zu kriegen. Das ist also alles andere als sicher. Allerdings, ein Drittel Wahrscheinlichkeit ist jetzt schon mal eine Hausnummer, wo man vielleicht sagt, das ignoriert man nicht so leicht. Es gibt aber auch andere Krankheiten, wo dann das Risiko, wenn es sich verdoppelt von 0, 5 Prozent auf 1 Prozent geht, da ist das Verdoppeln dann vielleicht nicht ganz so spannend tatsächlich.
Aber gibt es auch sozusagen ein anderes Extrem, dass man sagt, ok, du kriegst auf jeden Fall Augenkrebs?
Ob man was selbst bekommt? Jein, also gibt es bestimmt auch, aber es gibt, was für viele Leute spannender ist, einfach bist du Überträger von einer Erbkrankheit, also du bist nicht selbst betroffen, weil wenn dann würde das von Anfang an quasi von Geburt an ausgeprägt sein und man würde es sehen, aber du trägst nur eine defekte Kopie, aber wenn du jetzt Kinder zeugen solltest, besteht die Möglichkeit, dass du deinem Kind irgendwie dieses Krankheitsrisiko vererbst, zum einen, bzw. dieses eine Allee und wenn dein Partner das auch hat, dass tatsächlich dieser Gendefekt ausgeprägt sein wird.
Genau dazu würde ich gern was sagen und zwar zum einen habe ich meinen Blogpost von ihm eingelesen, der eben auch das bei 23Me eingeschickt hat, also eine Probe, und dann das wieder bekommen hat und er meinte, er wünschte, er hätte es nicht gemacht, weil er seitdem, also danach, richtig schlecht geschlafen hat und total übrüchrender wurde, weil da doch einige Sachen angesagt wurden, die kommen könnten. Und er sagte so, er hat immer das Gefühl, so ungefähr, er stirbt bald. Also das hat ihn ziemlich mitgenommen, das heißt, man sollte sich vorher genau klar sein, ich meine gut, die haben jetzt diesen Teil wieder rausgenommen, aber trotzdem, soll man sich genau klar sein, ob man das möchte und was das für einen bedeuten kann. Bei mir selbst weiß ich halt zum Beispiel durch gar nicht sowas, sondern in Kindertagen war ich irgendwie allergisch gegen Kuhmilch, ich bin ins Krankenhaus gekommen, die haben irgendwie genauer untersucht und auch ein Gendefekt bei mir festgestellt, der eben auch genau durch sowas kommt, wie Sebastian gesagt hat. Also meine Eltern haben das beide nicht, haben beide einer lehle, ich hatte Pech, ich habe genau die beiden bekommen, aber auch da ist es jetzt wieder, ich habe zwar diesen Gendefekt, der ist aber in einer Ausprägung, die so schwach ist, dass die einzige Konsequenz für mein Leben ist, dass ich nicht körperlich in der Lage bin, Trompeten oder sowas zu spielen. Da kann ich jetzt ganz gut mit leben. Ich weiß aber auch, dass wenn ich zum Beispiel rauchen würde, die Schäden, die ich davon nehme, ein vielfaches höher wären als bei anderen. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich eine gute Information für mich, dass ich weiß, Rauchen wäre für mich, wenn ich das anfange, viel destruktiver als bei anderen. Gleichzeitig heißt das, ich weiß, ich habe diese beiden kaputten Alleele, wenn ich mal Kinder haben möchte, habe ich mich selbst halt auch schon gefragt, will ich meinen Partner vorher testen? Denn diesen Defekt, den ich habe, ich habe den halt in der schwächsten Abstufung, die es gibt. Wenn man den in der stärksten hat, werden die Kinder nicht über ein Jahr. Und auch die anderen hohen Stufen sind dann so eher so, die Kinder werden 10, die Kinder werden 20 und dann ist vorbei. Das heißt, für mich ist es zum einen gut, es zu wissen. Auf der anderen Seite stehe ich vor einer ganz komischen Entscheidung, wenn ich mal Kinder kriege, ob ich meinen Partner testen lassen will. Und was ist das? Vor allem, was mache ich mit der Antwort? Ich meine, wenn es ist, ja, er hat das gar nicht, das Erlehrt. Das heißt, die Kinder können das nicht haben. Die kriegen ja nur eins von mir mit. Man kriegt ja immer von beiden Eltern einen Teil mit. Dann klar, wäre ich beruhigt. Aber was ist, wenn ich mitbekomme, der hat da eins. Dann ist die Chance 50-50, dass das Kind krank ist. Und dann ist wieder die Frage, in welcher Extremvariante hat das das? Das sind halt Sachen, da muss man wirklich... Also da hab ich auch für mich selbst noch keine Antwort gefunden, weil ich das immer nach hinten geschoben hab. Aber das sind Sachen, die machen solche Entscheidungen nicht einfacher.
Da kommen wir jetzt aber direkt zu dem Punkt Ethik in der Bioinformatik. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist tatsächlich ein ganz schwieriges Thema, weil es vielleicht auch Bestrebungen gibt, dass da Krankenkassen dann sagen, so eine Genom-Analyse, die könnte man auch eigentlich mal so bevölkerungsweit machen. Dann legen wir mal aufgrund davon neue Krankenkassensätze vor. Gibt es so eine Bestrebung?
In Deutschland gibt es einfach das Gen-Diagnostik-Gesetz, was zumindest Krankenkassen verbietet, tatsächlich solche Gentests einzufordern. Ich glaube, die Ausnahme davon, vielleicht kann mich weh korrigieren, wenn es falsch ist, sind Lebensversicherungen. Die haben tatsächlich irgendwie noch ein Anrecht darauf, informiert zu werden, wenn man schon einen Gentest hat und man weiß, dass man irgendwelche schlimmen Krankheiten bekommen wird. Dann haben die einen Anrecht darauf, das zu erfahren. Bei Krankenkassen ist tatsächlich momentan verboten, darüber quasi zu diskriminieren. Und ich meine, für Arbeitgeber gilt das Gleiche in Deutschland.
Auch schon ein interessanter Punkt, weil man den Gentest einmal gemacht hat, dann gibt es möglicherweise Leute, die darauf zugreifen können, dürfen, wollen. Das ist tatsächlich die Frage, ob man es tatsächlich macht. Und dann das andere ist natürlich auch so diese persönliche Erfahrung. Will man von jemand fordern, einen Genom im Gentest zu machen? Glaubt ihr, das kommt in Zukunft, dass das so selbstverständlicher wird? Dass man halt denkt, wenn ich mit dir eine langfristige Partnerschaft eingehe, dann guck doch mal bitte nach, was du so an Schäden hast.
Fast tatsächlich. Tatsächlich gab es, glaube ich, mal aus München sogar, irgendwie von der Uni, ein Start-up, das gegründet wurde, was Dating basierend auf Gentests machen wollte. Allerdings nicht, um zu schauen, ob die Kinder Krankheiten haben, sondern ich glaube über Immungene, die dann tatsächlich eher voraussagen, ob man sich gegenseitig riechen kann. Also ob der Geruch des Partners einem zusagt oder nicht.
Aber trotzdem noch die Frage, diese ethischen Überlegungen, spielen die schon eine Rolle? Oder ist Bioinformatik gerade noch so dieses Goldgräberstimmung? Ja, wir werden das Genom sequenzieren und so was. Oder gibt es da auch schon Arbeit zu?
Es gibt Arbeit dazu tatsächlich. Also die Biologie hat sich jetzt in der Vergangenheit insgesamt nicht so mit viel rumbekleckert über Bioethik selbst, muss man ja leider sagen. Nicht nur irgendwie in Deutschland in den 30er und 40er Jahren, sondern auch in anderen Bereichen irgendwie danach. Deshalb ist ziemlich stark ausgeprägte Ethiksysteme irgendwie wenn man mit Menschen forscht und die Bioinformatik ist davon natürlich auch betroffen und der Grund, warum halt menschliche Datensätze oft nicht frei verfügbar sind. Ich glaube, Lisa hat das angesprochen, dass eben das, was sie untersuchen wollte, da sind die Daten nicht frei verfügbar, ist häufig genau aus dem Grund, dass man eben sagt, wir müssen unsere Probanden schützen und deshalb sind diese Daten nicht frei verfügbar.
Wir sind jetzt hierhin gekommen und haben eine Runde unterbrochen, nämlich die zu erfahren, was die Gesprächspartner hier eigentlich, wie sie zur Bioinformatik gekommen sind und was sie da so tun oder getan haben. Carina fehlt da noch. Wie bist du zur Bioinformatik gekommen?
Ja, bei mir war das, dann hab ich überlegt, was ich so studieren will und bin dann irgendwie bei Informatik gelandet, hab dann überlegt, na, nur Informatik. Ich bin so ein Mensch, der kann sich nicht so ewig mit einem Thema beschäftigen. Ich brauch ein bisschen Abwechslung. Hab mir dann irgendwie Medieninformatik, ja, Wirtschaftsinformatik auch angeguckt. Ich kann mich nicht so richtig entscheiden. Dann hab ich irgendwie die Hochschule in St. August hingefunden und festgestellt, super, da muss ich mich erst im vierten Semester für einen Schwerpunkt entscheiden und hab alles, was ich mir so angeguckt habe, als Möglichkeit und hab dann einfach diese Entscheidung nach hinten verschoben. Hab dann da Informatik angefangen zu studieren, hatte dann irgendwann wo die Sachen vorgestellt und hab festgestellt bis dahin, also mir liegt Algorithmik, mir liegt Programmieren. Ja, das kann ich in der Bioinformatik machen, dann nehm ich das. Also es war ziemlich ungeplant, es kam dann spontan. Und dann bin ich da auch direkt so richtig eingestiegen. Das heißt, ich hab dann mein, irgendwie so ein Praxisprojekt, was wir in den Semesterferien machen mussten, dann da gemacht. Und bin am Fraunhofer Institut gelandet, also wirklich in der Forschung in der Abteilung Bioinformatik. Und hab dort halt im Bereich Image-Mining gearbeitet, also gar nicht in der klassischen Bioinformatik. Bin dann im Rahmen meines Studiums auch mal ins Ausland gegangen, nach Kanada, Halifax. Und hab da wirklich mich auf Bioinformatik fokussiert, in dem Semester, wo ich da war. Und da hab ich auch wirklich ein Forschungsprojekt gemacht. Und es gab zwei interessante Sachen. Also die eine interessante Sache war so, ich hatte vorher so einen Einführungskurs Bioinformatik, was es dann halt so an der Uni gibt, in Deutschland gemacht bei einem Informatiklehrer. Und bei diesen ganzen Vergleichen und so gibt es immer zwei Schritte. Das ist eines dieser phylogenetische Baum, von denen wir gerade schon gehört haben. Also da werden die einzelnen Gene, oder Genome oder Snippets, also irgendwie diese Stücke, die ich vergleichen will, sozusagen sortiert schon mal nach Ähnlichkeit. Und danach macht man die eigentlichen Vergleiche. Und der meinte immer, dieses Sortieren in diesen Baum ist total trivial, das machen wir einfach. Aber dieses Vergleichen, das ist das, wo die Komplexität ist. Und da gibt es Algorithmen und da haben wir uns ganz intensiv mit beschäftigt. Und dann bin ich da nach Kanada gekommen und saß, im Endeffekt der gleichen Vorlesung, aber gehalten von Biologen. Und der meinte, naja, also hier diese Bäume machen, sodass man es richtig sortiert. Und so, da ist die ganze Intelligenz. Das ist das Schwierige. Das ist das, wo wir unser Wissen reinstecken. Danach die Vergleiche. Da gibt es hier so eine Software, die heißt Blast. Da kippen wir das rein und dann tut das das. Und wir saßen da so im Moment. Und da habe ich gelernt, dass es beides total komplex ist. Aber je nachdem aus welchem Bereich du kommst, ob du ein Informatiker bist oder ein Biologe, hast du halt einen anderen Fokus und eine andere Sicht da drauf. Und das fand ich schon mal sehr, sehr spannend, weil ich dann einfach gelernt habe, dass man auch in der Uni einfach nicht die Wahrheit lernt. Und dann haben wir dort ein Forschungsprojekt gemacht, was auch sehr spannend war, wofür sich der eine oder andere Zuhörer mit identifizieren kann. Das ist nämlich Grippe. Ich hab mir angeschaut, wie entsteht eigentlich andauernd neue Grippe. Also das Problem, vielleicht muss man mal klären, wie Grippe sich denn so verbreitet. Also ich rede jetzt hier nicht von dieser Kältung mit Husten und Schnuppen, wo alle sagen, ich hab eine Grippe, sondern die echte Grippe, wo man mit Fieber und allem richtig flach liegt. Und das ist ja ein Virus, der in den Körper geht und die Zelle befällt. Und was da passiert ist, dieses Genom tritt, oder dieser Virus kommt in die Zelle und löst sich erstmal auf. Und selbst das Genom zerlegt sich in seine Bestandteile, in acht Gene. Diese Gene schwirren sozusagen in der Zelle rum und irgendwann, wenn die Zelle stirbt, baut sich das wieder zusammen, der Virus. Das heißt, er nimmt dann wieder seine acht Gene und geht weiter. Wenn jetzt jemand schon Grippe hat einer Art, also sagen wir H1N1, das ist so eine Grippe, die schon seit Ewigkeiten existiert. Also eigentlich war die schon mal ausgerottet, aber die Russen waren nicht so vorsichtig im Labor. Jetzt gibt's sie wieder. Oder H5N1, das war halt hier die bekannte Vogelgrippe, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht vertue. Die, sagen wir mal, hat halt zwei davon. Dann passiert es, dass die sich beide auflösen. Und wenn dann die Zelle stirbt, gehen wieder acht Gene, auch je eins von jedem Typ, also es gibt auch verschiedene Typen, zusammen. Und bilden wieder eine neue, sozusagen wieder eine Grippe. Virus, so ein Kleines. Aber wenn da zwei drin waren, nimmt das halt nicht jetzt genau die acht, die vorher zusammengehörten mit, sondern vielleicht eins von dem einen, sieben von dem anderen oder fünf zu drei. Also der mischt sich. Und das, was da rausfällt, kann sein, dass das gar nicht lebensfähig ist, weil die Stücke gar nicht so gut zusammenpassen. Es kann aber auch passieren, dass das lebensfähig ist. Und dann gibt es eigentlich zwei Sachen, die gemessen werden. Das eine ist, wie einfach Leute angesteckt werden und wie pathogen, also wie tödlich eigentlich oder wie stark die Erkrankung ist. Die perfekte Kombination ist der Virus, der sich am Schluss durchsetzt. Deswegen haben wir immer wieder neue Grippewellen. Jedes Jahr muss man sich, wenn man sich impfen geht, neu impfen oder es hilft selbst dann nicht, weil sich das immer weiter verändert. Das Interessante ist, dass es bedeutet, dass jede neue Grippeart genau in einem Menschen entstanden ist. Und man das im Nachhinein nachvollziehen kann auf exakt die Person, wo das herkommt. Das ist ziemlich spannend, weil man einfach sehen kann, wir haben jetzt diesen Grippe-Strang. Die Grippe ist meldepflichtig. Die Ärzte, wenn du da hinkommst, nehmen einen Test und schicken das ein und das wird gemeldet. Dann wissen die, okay, hier ist das entstanden. Dann konnten wir gucken, wo gab es dieser neue, den wir jetzt haben, aus welchen zwei ist der gemischt worden? Oder ist dieser aus zweien gemischt worden? Und wenn ja, aus welchen genau? Da vergleicht man wieder riesen Datenmengen. Und welche Teile wurden getauscht? Also welche Gene wurden getauscht? Das nennt sich Reassortments, also wird so umsortiert. Da habe ich in diesem Forschungsprojekt wirklich neue Reassortments festgestellt. Also ich habe ein riesen Datenset mir runtergeladen. Typisch Bioinformatik heißt, man hat eine Menge Tools, die es gibt, wo man dann die Parameter und so anpasst für sich. Und eine Menge Skripte schreibt, die die ganzen Datenformate umformen, weil die sich alle nicht einigen können, welches Datenformat die benutzen. Ich glaube, das kennt jeder von euch. Jeder Bioinformatiker schreibt vor allem Skripte, die sowas machen. Und ja, das war dann so mein Forschungsergebnis, war dann eine Abhandlung und eine Vorstellung von irgendwie, ich glaube, fünf oder sechs neuen Reassortments, die bis dato auch keiner gefunden hatte. Wo ich sagen konnte, okay, diese Grippestränge, die wir kennen, sind genau an dieser Stelle dort passiert. Und dann sprang so in mir auf der einen Seite der Forschern und auf der anderen Seite der Datenschützer. Ich dachte, boah, wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wie diese Leute gereist sind und wo die sich aufgehalten haben, dann könnte ich genau sehen, wie exakt diese Grippe wirklich von Person zu Person gesprungen ist und das ganz genau nachvollziehen. Und der Datenschützer in mir hat natürlich geschrien, so, oh mein Gott, das ist komplette Überwachung, die wir brauchen. Der Forscher dachte, boah, wenn ich das bloß hätte, das wär so geil, ich könnte so viel rausfinden. Und das ist auch so ein ganz großes Dilemma, was man hat. Weil natürlich mir auf der anderen Seite klar ist, würden wir diese Daten erheben, selbst mit den besten Intentionen. Sie würden auf der fatalste Weise genutzt werden können und es würde natürlich passieren, dass Daten, die erhoben sind, werden genutzt für alles. Und das fand ich einen sehr interessanten Konflikt, in den man da einfach kommt. Und wo ich immer so ein bisschen auch merkte, die Biologen-Kollegen, die sich noch nicht so mit der Informatik und dem Datenschutz auseinandergesetzt hatten, waren teilweise ein bisschen, hatten halt nicht diese Bedenken, die auf der anderen Seite standen, sondern dachten nur, wir brauchen diese Daten.
Hättest du dir wieder stehen können, wenn jemand auf dem Silberwetter-Tablett gesagt hätte, so hier, guck mal, da sind die Daten, willst du vielleicht mal kurz reingucken?
Naja, also ich könnte dir wieder stehen, weil ich sozusagen schon verurteilen würde, das Erfassen, weil das Erfassen dieser Daten ist halt nichts Triviales. Hier geht es nicht um irgendwelche Zuordnungen oder so, sondern es geht darum, dass man eine totale Überwachung der Reisebewegung aller Personen bräuchte auf dieser Welt und mit wem die auch interagieren, damit man wüsste, wo, wie, was entstanden ist. Das sind einfach Dinge, die gehen viel zu weit in die Privatsphäre, als dass man das irgendwie gut heißen könnte. Aber es gab schon interessante Projekte auch so. Also gerade bei älteren Datensätzen, wo die Leute noch nicht so viel gereist sind, also vor einigen Jahrzehnten schon, gibt es einfach schöne Overlays für Google Earth, wo man dann sieht, wie eben so aus Asien so langsam die Grippe rüber wandert. Und da gibt es dann auch etwas neuere Sätze, wo man einfach sieht, wie extrem das beschleunigt ist und auch Sprünge hat von üblichen Reisen. Wo man plötzlich sieht, die Grippe hat einen halben Kontinent innerhalb von ein paar Tagen übersprungen, weil irgendjemand krank gereist ist und dann die Nächsten wieder infiziert hat. Auch jetzt kann man da schon einiges sehen, was ganz schön beeindruckend ist. Und vorhin hatte ich die Geschichte schon erzählt und da war direkt die Assoziation zu diesem Spiel, was es gibt. Genau, da wird ja genau so was simuliert. Und da geht es eben auch um, dass man einen Virus entwickelt. Ich habe es gar nicht gespielt, aber sagt mir, wenn ich was falsch sage. Aber da geht es ja auch darum, dass man einen Virus entwickelt, der genau diese Eigenschaften hat, zwischen dem, dass er sich gut weiterverbreitet und dann die Leute in der richtigen Zeit sterben. Weil wenn die Leute zu schnell wegsterben, also krank werden, also infiziert sind, sofort krank sind, sofort sterben, sonst werden keine neuen Leute infiziert.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr großartiges Spiel. Man fängt mit dem Virus an und kann dann immer auswählen, soll er ansteckender sein, soll er Resistenzen entwickeln, wie hoch soll die Mortalitätsrate sein. Kann ich ihm natürlich nur empfehlen.
Das Krasse, was viele nicht wissen, also bei der Grippe, dieses H1N1 oder H2N3, was man so gehört hat, das ist H und N, das sind zwei Buchstaben, die jetzt für den Namen identifizieren, welches Gen es ist in diesem Genom. Und zwar sind das die zwei, die die Oberfläche beschreiben. Nur wenn sich die Oberfläche verändert, ist das auch eine Veränderung für unser Immunsystem. Und wir erkennen es plötzlich nicht mehr, weil es anders aussieht. Deswegen werden diese Zahlen genommen zum Identifizieren. Weil natürlich nur wenn sich die Oberfläche nicht in etwas verändert, reagiert plötzlich das Immunsystem da nicht drauf. Und was natürlich alle dann so sich gefragt haben, welche Mischungen kannst du so geben, die dann besonders gefährlich wären? Dann ist wirklich ein Wissenschaftler im Labor hingegangen und hat so ein bisschen den bösen, verrückten Wissenschaftler gespielt. Der hat nämlich alle Formen, die bekannt sind schon, einmal durchkombiniert und dann geguckt an Tierchen, wie dann jetzt plötzlich die Tierchen schnell sterben und die Ansteckungen...
Hat er einen Supergrippevirus entwickelt?
Also der hat eigentlich genau Plague gespielt, nur in echt. Und hat dann auch rausgefunden, welcher der nächste wäre, der wie die spanische Grippe im Ersten Weltkrieg, die über zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung infiziert hat, denn die nächste große Gefahr wäre. Wo ich mir auch dachte, nach dem Vorfall mit den Russen, die nicht auf ihr Zeug aufgepasst haben, fand ich das ein bisschen gruselig, aber wir hatten Glück. Aber das existiert immer noch in einem Schrank, in einem Labor. Weil man das auch braucht, um dann schnell einen Impfstoff entwickeln zu können, wenn das ausbricht.
Puh, dank Bioinformatik wurde schon die Supergrippe entwickelt. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Um das zu verdauen, haben wir jetzt eine kleine Musik. Dann geht es in die letzte halbe Stunde. Chaosradio 211 aus der Marienstraße 11 im Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Heute zum Thema Bioinformatik mit Lisa. Mit Carina. Mit Carina.
Hallo.
Und Bastian. Hi. Ah, sehr schön, alle noch da. Aber ihr seid vielleicht schon abgeschreckt, denn wir haben in den letzten anderthalb Stunden viel gelernt, nämlich also Bioinformatik ist, ich drücke es mal despektierlich aus, vor allen Dingen langweiliges Arbeiten mit Algorithmen. Ausgeliefert ist man der Industrie, die möglichst neues Viagra erfinden will und außerdem ermöglicht es datenschutzbedenkliche Forschung am menschlichen Genom und führt dazu, dass Leute super grippivieren entwickeln.
Das waren die Biologen, also momentan, so geht es nicht.
Natürlich waren es die Biologen möglicherweise, aber wir haben ja gelernt, dass sozusagen durch die Faltungen von Genomen und die Computerausrechnung der Formen, man viel leichter so eine Dinge machen kann als vorher, weil die Informatiker durch voll dynamische Algorithmen dafür sorgt, dass diese ganzen Proteste optimiert werden.
Ne, ne, ne, also das mit dem Grippivirus, das war kombinatorisch, das kann man mit einem Taschenrechner machen.
Jaja, das hätte ich jetzt anstelle eines Bioinformatikers auch gesagt. Wir wollen die letzte verbleibende Zeit dafür nutzen, um mal zu sagen, falls Leute, die jetzt trotz dieser Horrormeldungen nicht abgeschreckt wurden, denken so, ja Bioinformatik vielleicht ein ganz interessantes Ding, wo andere Knüpfungspunkte für die wären. Und da würde ich jetzt erstens gerne die Frage stellen, ist das denn was, wo man sich nur für interessieren sollte, wenn man das jetzt irgendwie studieren will oder das wirklich ernsthaft betreiben will, oder ist das tatsächlich auch was, was man so als Neben-Hobby noch betreiben kann?
Neben-Hobby, vielleicht können wir auch noch, das ist jetzt ein bisschen kurz gekommen, tatsächliche lebensnahe Beispiele und Anwendungen.
Da habe ich die ganze Zeit nach gefragt und du hast immer gesagt, nein, man kann sich keine grünen Fingernägel wachsen lassen.
Okay, ich bin nicht ganz sicher, was du mit den grünen Fingernägeln hast, aber das ist wieder Biologie. Also wenn es denn keine Bits mehr sind, dann ist das Biologie. Aber ich glaube, da gab es sogar schon mal Bestrebungen Bierbrauen. Und zwar ging es da konkret um die Berliner Weiße, die ursprüngliche alte und Ähnliches mit Weinherstellung. Und sehr viele andere Lebensmittelprozesse, wo Mikroorganismen daran beteiligt sind. Da sind die Arten von Mikroorganismen tatsächlich wichtig. Also die original Berliner Weiße braucht eigentlich genau diesen Stamm von Milchsäurebakterien, der da ursprünglich benutzt wurde. Und ich weiß nicht, ob der Mensch, der sich damit beschäftigt hat, das verfolgt hat, aber man könnte natürlich auch sequenzieren und gucken. Also so alte, nicht mehr so richtig wiederzubelebende Milchsäurebakterien aus alten Berliner Weißflaschen, die jetzt schon so 100 Jahre alt sind oder so, sequenzieren und gucken, inwiefern die sich von den entsprechenden Kulturen, die man heute noch so bekommt, unterscheiden. Ob man da irgendwo einen möglichst nah dran Stamm herbekommt. Ähnlich ist halt bei Sachen wie Käse, Kombucha, solche Geschichten. Also lebensmitteltechnisch tunen und untersuchen für die Leute, die sich furchtbar gerne mit Lebensmitteln beschäftigen. Das nächste ist genau das andere Ende. Alle reden gerne über Kacke. Ja, ist ein wichtiger Forschungszweig. Mikrobiomen. Also in unserem Verdauungstrakt leben viele, viele Mikroorganismen. Die sind auch wichtig. Es gibt sehr viel Forschung, sehr viel Vermutung drüber, dass welche Mikroorganismen da genau leben, einen starken Einfluss auf die Gesundheit, auf so etwas wie Übergewicht, Untergewicht, möglicherweise sogar Laktoseintoleranz, lauter so Geschichten haben. Da gibt es, glaube ich, schon einige Bestrebungen von Leuten, die das jetzt einfach für sich wissen wollen, ob vielleicht einfach ihr Mikrobiom daran schuld ist, dass sie übergewichtig sind, ob man das vielleicht ändern kann, solche Geschichten. Da regelmäßig immer mal Abstriche machen, das sequenzieren lassen und gucken, wenn sie jetzt vier Wochen lang völlig auf Zucker verzichtet haben, ob sich das Mikrobiom dann verändert hat. Ich glaube, Bastian, du hattest doch mal irgendwie so Mikrobiom-Sequenzen da auswerten gemacht, oder?
Ja, genau. Es gibt ähnlich wie 23andMe, die einem das eigene Genom sequenzieren. Auch, ich glaube, U-Biome heißt die Firma, kommt auch aus den USA, denen man dann lustig seine Mikrobiom-Samples schicken kann. Also tatsächlich irgendwie nicht nur aus dem Magen-Darm-Bereich, sondern auch aus dem Mund und irgendwie, was auf der Haut so wächst. Und dann kann man denen, wenn man möchte, eben regelmäßig Proben schicken und kann dann schauen, wie sich über die Zeit die Bakterien, der Bakterienbewuchs auf und im Körper sich verändert. Das klingt echt fies. Man muss auch sagen, dass irgendwie, was ganz spannend ist, das steckt noch ziemlich in den Kinderschuhen. Und das ist relativ viel glaskuglesen bislang noch, gerade mit diesem Mikrobiomzeug. Also natürlich, wenn man einfach zweimal einen Abstrich nimmt, wird man eigentlich immer was anderes finden. Und inwieweit das biologisch relevant ist oder einfach ein Artifakt davon, dass man zwei Abstriche gemacht hat, statt nur einem, ist in vielen Punkten, glaube ich, noch fragwürdig.
Aber schon halt irgendwie interessant und mit Potenzial für Dinge.
Genau, es ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Und ich glaube, wenn man für diese zufälligen Faktoren irgendwann mal ganz gut korrigieren kann, auch sicherlich sehr spannend. Bislang sollte man vielleicht nicht blind diesen Ergebnissen immer vertrauen. Also wenn man dann drei Wochen auf Zucker verzichtet hat und am Ende der drei Wochen sieht man auf einmal andere Bakterien, ob das zwingend damit zusammenhängt, dass man auf Zucker verzichtet hat. Wer weiß.
Ihr habt ja alle mal damit angefangen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, so eine Möglichkeit ist so in die Richtung zu gehen, was ich in meinem Forschungsprojekt gemacht habe. Also diese Daten sind halt frei verfügbar. Es gibt da von NCBI eine große Datenbank. Da kann man sich verschiedenste Sachen runterladen und einfach mal gucken. Also ich fand halt was bei Grippe total spannend, weil es eigentlich recht gut dokumentiert ist, wie man da vorzugehen hat. Die Tools sind auch alle frei verfügbar. Das ist jetzt nichts, was man irgendwie nicht drankommt. Sie sind sogar oft übers Web ansteuerbar. Das heißt, man muss das gar nicht lokal bei sich rechnen, sondern man schickt ihnen die Daten und kriegt dann irgendwann eine Mail, so wir sind jetzt fertig mit Rechnen. Für die ganz großen Datenmengen klappt das nicht, aber für die kleinen ersten Experimente schon ganz gut. Und dann kann man einfach so ein bisschen mal gucken, wie hängen denn Gene zusammen, wo gibt es Unterschiede? Und wie gesagt, man guckt sich halt gar nicht unbedingt ein ganzes Gen an, sondern nur bestimmte Bereiche, die interessant sind. Da gibt es dann auch diese Ausschnitte schon fertig, in wirklich tausenden Varianten. Man kann einfach mal gucken, wo sind Unterschiede? Wo ist alles bei wirklich Hunderten identisch? Oder plötzlich hat man einen Ausreißer und kann man sich den genauer angucken, wo kommt der her?
Gibt es auch sozusagen so Tutorial-Aufgaben, wo man quasi sagen kann, hier versuch doch mal das und das, und dann müsstest du das Ergebnis bekommen.
Ja, es gibt eine sehr schöne Plattform namens Rosalind, was einfach ein interaktives Programmiertutorial für Bioinformatik-Aufgaben ist.
Das ist sehr schick gemacht. Wer das Projekt Euler kennt, was eher aus der reinen Informatik kommt, also das sind Mathematik-Informatik-Aufgaben bei Projekt Euler, gibt es eben mit Rosalind auch für die Bioinformatik, wo man eigentlich fast kein Vorwissen in der Biologie braucht und auch fürs Programmieren fängt das relativ einfach an. Also wenn man sich mal tatsächlich von ganz Grund auf einarbeiten will, ist das ein ganz guter Start.
Und ich glaube auch, wenn man aus der Informatik kommt, kann man auch tatsächlich über Bücher einsteigen. Also ich hab eine Kanten, die hat sich auf ein Jobinterview vorbereitet und ist dann quasi in ein Bioinformatikproblem reingefallen und hat sich ein Buch gekauft, das heißt Algorithms and Strings, Trees and Sequences von Dan Gasfield. Und da geht es um reine Algorithmik ohne allzu längliche Bioerklärungen, würde ich sagen. Und er meinte, er konnte das auch so lesen und fand es so spannend, dass er es komplett durchgearbeitet hat.
Vorhin hat einer von euch noch etwas über Metagenomik oder so ähnlich gesagt. Es sollte noch ein Punkt sein, den wir unbedingt erwähnen sollten. Noch mehr? Dann müssen wir uns aber langsam beeilen.
Ein Buch, was ich noch prima fand zum Einstieg für Informatik ist Introduction to Computational Genomics von Christian Nini, was so ein bisschen geschichtenmäßig aufgebaut ist. Jedes Kapitel hat eine Geschichte, wie viel Neandertaler steckt eigentlich in uns und wie funktioniert eigentlich ein Zirkadianer Rhythmen. Und in jedem Kapitel durcharbeitet, wie man da mit Methoden der Bioinformatik rangehen würde. Das ist sehr hübsch gemacht und es liest sich auch gut weg. Sonst noch Coursera hat ein paar sehr schöne Bioinformatik Kurse. Pavel Pevtsna.
Was ist Coursera? Was ist das?
Coursera ist eine großartige Plattform für Uni-Kurse im Internet. Also wirklich mit Video Lectures und wöchentlichen Übungsaufgaben und Praktika und Foren, wo man sich mit anderen Studenten austauschen kann. Super, ganz großartig. Und man kann die Videos auf doppelte Geschwindigkeit stellen.
Alright, noch mehr?
Also es gibt auch noch ein paar, ich weiß gar nicht, hier in Berlin bin ich gar nicht so bewandert, aber es gibt halt auch ein paar Hacker-Spaces, die sich mit diesen ganzen Thematiken beschäftigen. Also ich war jetzt vor kurzem in Prag und bin da in ein Hacker-Space gelaufen, weil ich das irgendwie in jeder Stadt, wo ich zu Besuch bin, gerne mal mache. Und die hatten auch einen ganzen Biohack-Bereich im Keller irgendwie und es war auch total spannend, was die da gemacht haben. Das war auch so, ja manches ging es echt in chemische, da haben sie irgendwie aus Chili-Pulver, das, wie heißt das, was das so scharf macht? Genau, das haben sie versucht da raus zu extrahieren. Und also die verschiedensten Sachen hatten die da, wo die einfach so von eher Chemielevel bis eben wirklich in die Bioinformatik gegangen sind, das war schon sehr spannend. Da muss man halt auch einfach mal gucken, was es so gibt.
Fahrt nach Prag, trinkt gutes Bier und geht in den Biohackspace. Okay, ich würde zum Abschluss noch gerne von jedem von euch noch so eine typische Abschlussfrage noch mal stellen, und zwar dieses, was ihr glaubt, was das nächste große Ding in der Bioinformatik ist, Bastian?
Das nächste große Ding in der Bioinformatik, ich glaube, weil ich viel dieses ganze Puzzlen von unbekannten Organismen mache, ist, dass wir endlich längere Wörter lesen können. Momentan haben wir das Problem, dass unsere Maschinen, mit denen wir Genome versuchen, auszulesen, vielleicht die, die weit verbreitet sind, schaffen es, 250 Zeichen am Stück zu lesen, und dann hört das Wort auf. Und aus 250 zeichenlangen Worten dann die 3 Milliarden wieder zusammen zu puzzeln, ist echt doof. Und es gibt mittlerweile Sequenziermaschinen, die einfach winzig sind und super lange Wörter lesen können. Also Oxford Nanopore zum Beispiel ist eine Technik, die ist USB Memory Stick groß, wird auch über USB einfach an den Laptop angeschlossen und man kann sequenzieren und kriegt dann 130.000 zeichnelange Worte, die das ganze Puzzlen viel einfacher machen und dass man es einfach USB Stick groß in seinen Rechner anschließt. Man kann auf einmal überall sequenzieren. Also wenn man sagt, man geht in den Dschungel und sammelt als Biologe Proben im Feld, kann man auch das Sequenzieren gleich im Feld machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das nächste große Ding ist, aber es ist vielleicht mein nächstes große Ding. Metagenomik, ziemlich spannende, ist auch ein bisschen ein Buzzword, gebe ich dazu. Grundproblem ist, klassisch in der Mikrobiologie studiert man Organismen, indem man sie, ob Petrischeien oder sonst was, in Kultur anzüchtet. Das Problem ist, dass nur sehr wenige Organismen da tatsächlich so drauf wachsen. Viele Mikroorganismen wachsen eigentlich nur in ihrer Umgebung, in Kollektiven mit anderen Mikroorganismen. Das heißt, man kann die nicht so richtig gut studieren. Aber jetzt können wir ja alles sequenzieren und können ganze Kollektive von Mikroorganismen, die voneinander abhängig sind und ohne einander gar nicht leben können, untersuchen, unterforschen und gucken, wie die zusammenarbeiten. Und das finde ich immer gespannt.
Ja, ich würde mich da anschließen. Metagenomik ist auf jeden Fall ein großes Ding. Und ich glaube, dass wir in Daten ertrinken werden. Also ich glaube, das passiert schon, dadurch, dass wir halt viel schneller sequenzieren können und mehr sequenzieren können und es auch günstiger wird. Es gab dann solche Projekte wie dieses 1000 Genomes Project, wo die 1000 Genome sequenziert haben, aber 1000 Menschen mit Genome. Genau.
Nicht 1000 Bakterien, sondern 1000 Menschen mit Genome.
Das sind super viele Daten. Und die Frage ist, wer soll die alle verarbeiten? Und das ist meine große Frage an die Zukunft der Bioinformatik, würde ich sagen. Wie gehen wir mit diesen großen Datenmengen um? Da gibt es auch dieses tolle Buzzword Big Data. Aber wer soll das eigentlich alles verarbeiten? Also es fällt jetzt halt viel schneller an, als man es analysieren kann.
Vielleicht neue Maschinen, vielleicht noch eine Hame von Bioinformatikern.
Ja, für mich ist so das nächste große Ding, auf das ich gespannt bin, vor allem personalisierte Medizin. Also gibt es jetzt schon im Kleinen, dass wirklich genau auf die Hygiene geguckt wird von irgendwie Tumoren oder so, das sequenziert wird. Da hatte Lisa von, glaube ich, auch was kurz zu gesagt. Also als wir uns unterhalten haben. Das finde ich total spannend, wo einfach geguckt wird, was liegt denn da genau vor, um die Diagnostik noch genau zu machen und dann eben auch die ganz exakte Therapie dafür zu finden. Zum Beispiel.
Sehr schön. Bastian, Carina, Linse und Lisa für einen kleinen zweistündigen Einstück in die Bioinformatik. Vielen Dank. Das war auf jeden Fall sehr spannend und auch ein bisschen gruselig, wie ich finde. Und ich bin gespannt, was ihr davon haltet. Könnt ihr gerne noch in die Kommentare schreiben unter chaosradio.ccc.de, wo dann auch demnächst der Podcast dieser Sendung erscheinen wird. Wir machen jetzt hier noch, bevor wir ganz verschwinden. Und ich wünsche euch einen guten Abend und noch einen kleinen Werbeblock. Denn es ist jetzt so Anfang des Jahres die Zeit, wo die ganzen tausend Millionen Konferenzen und Veranstaltungen an den Start kommen. Da dürfen wir ganz herzlich vom Chaos Computer Club Berlin den Herrn Erdgeist begrüßen, der gerade hierher wandelt. Aua und mich tritt an den Mikrofon. Und Monique, in ihrer Funktion, weiß ich gar nicht. Ich kenne sie von den Freifunkern, aber vielleicht noch auch in einer anderen Funktion hier.
Ja, doch schon Freifunker und Mitglied im Förderverein Freien Netzwerke.
Sehr gut, so ihr habt jetzt irgendwie noch, ihr habt nur noch ein paar Minuten Zeit, aber wollt ungefähr 50.000 Veranstaltungen dem geneigten Hörer ans Herz legen. Wir fangen an mit Hass.
Es sind nur sieben. Nein, wir fangen an mit dem Kongress der Möglichkeiten. Das ist koorganisiert vom Hate-Magazin und vom Chaos Computer Club. Das ist vom 30. April bis zum 10. Mai. Obwohl so richtig los geht es dann so am 8. 9. 10. wenn da die Workshops und Diskussionsrunden, Performances sind. In dieser Konferenz geht es darum, für Künstler und Menschen, die die Welt verändern wollen, in der aktuellen, durch technisierten und überwachtenden Gesellschaft noch Lebensräume zu finden. Finde ich toll spannend. Das ist in Betanien, in Berlin. Und am 30. ist die Vernissage.
Das war quasi heute.
Du hast recht, heute war oder ist die Vernissage. Nächster Termin ist die Republika, 5. bis 7. Mai. So wie die Blogosphäre, Masse, 450 Speaker, 300 Stunden pro Gramm, 6000 Teilnehmer. Und weiß nicht, ob man viel über die Republika noch erzählen muss. In Wirklichkeit trifft man sich einfach im großen Hof zum Bier.
Manche sagen so, manche sagen so. Astro Alex soll da sein, was ich sehr spannend finde.
Ja, diverse spannende Speaker sind da, aber die werden ja auch gestreamt. Und Tickets kann man sich den Eintrittspreis sparen, wenn man eine Schicht dort engelt. Ansonsten sind es 99 Euro für Studenten oder 99 Euro regulär. Nächste Veranstaltung ist vom 7. bis 10. Mai die KryptoCon in Leipzig. Da macht das Sublab unter dem Motto alles Blümchenwiese. Eine Konferenz, wo es darum geht, um praktische Verschlüsselung und wie Politik und Gesellschaft das Recht darauf einfließen zu nehmen. Und welche Freiräume man als Nörd hat, um anderen Menschen Kryptographie beizubringen. Aber es ist halt auch an Autonormalbürger gerichtet. Da hat ein gewisser Herr Erdgeist zuhört aufgeschrieben. Ja, ich wurde zur Kinoat geladen. Am 7. ist dann noch so ein Sozialprogramm. Und die Vorträge finden dann auch am Wochenende statt. Also am 9. und 10. Mai.
Man kann quasi durchgehend sich auf Konferenzen rumtreiben. Dann ist aber erst mal vier Tage Pause. Und dann beginnt am 14. Mai die Open-Tech-Summit in Berlin. Worum geht es da?
Ja, die Open-Tech-Summit dreht sich um alle möglichen Open-Everything-Themen. Die Idee ist, verschiedene Gruppen zusammenzubringen. Aus den Bereichen Open-Hardware, Free-Software, Libre-Graphics, aber auch Themen wie Internet und Gesellschaft anzusprechen, Lizenzen, Patente und so weiter. Wir haben ein paar ganz spannende Gäste. Mitch Altman wird einen Löt-Workshop beispielsweise bei uns geben. Oder Andi wird eine Strickmaschine live hacken. Freifunker werden Flasher-Workshops oder Router flaschen. Ganz viele bunte Vorträge wird es geben. Und wenn ihr jetzt auf die opentechsummit.net geht und dort ein Ticket kaufen möchtet, könnt ihr auch einfach nichts bezahlen und ein Code Chaosradio eingeben. Und dann gibt es ein paar Freitickets hier.
Gilt das auch für die Leute, die den Podcast noch hören?
Auch.
Wo ist das nochmal?
Das ist in der Kalkscheune in Berlin. Und los geht's am 14. Mai um 10 Uhr. Bis ungefähr 17.30 Uhr werden so Vorträge-Workshops sein. Und abends gibt es noch die Himmelfahrts-Open-Tech-Summit-Lounge mit ein bisschen Musik.
Und dann noch danach gleich das Wireless-Community-Vigent.
Genau. Das gibt es im Anschluss in der Seabase. Da treffen sich wie schon seit gefühlten 100 Jahren die Freifunker aus ganz Deutschland mit ihren internationalen Gästen. Ja und wie immer ist da das Motto hacken, grillen, chillen. Und wenig später im August.
Was geht dann los?
Da geht es nochmal weiter mit den Violet Communities. Das treffen ja europäische Violet Communities. Das ist sogenannte Battle Mesh. Da treten also Protokolle und Firmware gegeneinander an. Und ja, das ist dieses Jahr in Slowenien, in Maribor, vom 3. bis zum 9. August.
Und dann bleibt natürlich noch...
Dann geht es danach direkt zum?
Zum Camp. Dieses Jahr ist Camp und dieses Jahr haben wir eine total geile Location, habe ich auf dem Kongress schon erzählt. So eine ehemalige Ziegelei, die jetzt zur Konferenz-Area ausgebaut worden ist. Und da gibt es so, naja, Baggaseen würde man sagen, da ist irgendwie Granate in der Nier. Also man kann planschen. Da gibt es so 3 Sienenzonen, damit spielen, so eine Zuganlage, eine Lokomotive. Und es werden 2 Vortragszelte aufgebaut, wie man vom Camp halt kennt. Also nicht so dringend durchgeplant wie auf dem Kongress. Aber da gibt es Vortragsprogramm, auch ein paar spannende Vorträge. Und einer der bei mir wichtigsten Tracks ist, dass es diesmal einen Philosophietrack gibt, der sich sehr aggressiv und aktiv mit der Fehlerkultur der Nerds auseinandersetzen soll. Wie man damit umgeht, dass Leute natürlich Fehler machen. Wie man die Leute dann darauf drängt, irgendwie mit den Fehlern so offen umzugehen, dass sie sich nicht blamieren oder es gar nicht nach draußen bringen. Weil auch andere Leute können natürlich von Fehlern lernen. Und ich denke, die Hacker-Szene kann da von einer neuen Fehlerkultur nur profitieren.
Fehler machen wir im Chaos Communication Camp in Ziegelpark im Mildenberg im August. Ah ja, Fehler machen kann man auch bei der Republika.
Das ist Datum, noch eine 13. bis 17. August dieses Jahres.
Wir haben viel zu lange gebraucht. Auch das ist ein Fehler in dieser Matrix, in dieser Sendung. Vielen Dank nochmal allen Beteiligten. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß. Hört den Podcast, kommentiert, empfehlt uns weiter. Und ansonsten hören wir uns bald wieder. Mir bleibt immer noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.